CAN ESTABLISH A QUORUM PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
SENATORS MITCHELL HERE BATES
[inaudible]
MINING.
NIELSEN.
PAN.
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
INNER [inaudible]
STONE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS.
THERE ARAMBULA [inaudible]
BLOOM [inaudible]
MELENDEZ [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE.
REVERSE.
WEBER YOU.
DO WE HAVE A PLAN IN THE EVENT
THAT ALL THESE ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS SHOW WHERE THEY'RE GOING
TO SET --
JOHN YES.
YES WE HAVE A PLAN SHOW YOU HAVE
A PLAN FOR WHERE ALL THE
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS WITH IT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. FOR MEMBERS THAT
MAYNOT KNOW JENNIFER TROY IS
THE STAFF MEMBER TO THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE.
AND WHAT THE QUORUM OF FIVE
MEMBERS FROM EACH HOUSE HAVING
BEEN ESTABLISHED AT LIKE TO GO
AHEAD.
AND CALL TODAY'S HEARING TO
ORDER.
TODAY'S HEARING IS GOING TO BE
BASICALLY IN THREE PARTS AS
REFLECTED IN YOUR AGENDA.
THE FIRST GOAL OF OUR HEARING
TODAY IS OPERATIONAL WHERE WE
ARE HAVE TO ESTABLISH IN THAT
THIS IS THE FIRST MEETING OUT --
THIS CURRENT LEGISLATIVE SESSION
WE'VE GOT A DOCTOR COMMITTEE
RULES ON AND ELECT A CHAIR AND
VICE CHAIR.
SECONDLY I'M GONNA PROVIDE A
BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE JAIL B.
C.'S RESPONSIBILITY YOU KNOW
THIS COMMITTEE IS COMMONLY --
MISTAKEN FOR EVEN THE BUDGET
CONFERENCE --
ALL THREE OF THOSE INTO TV'S
ENTITIES ARE SEPARATE AND EACH
HAVE.
A DISTINCTIVE FUNCTIONS THAT
THEY SERVE ON BEHALF OF THE
LEGISLATURE SOME GOING TO SPEND
A LITTLE TIME PROVIDING CLARITY
TO OURSELVES AND EVERYONE ABOUT
THE ABSOLUTE.
UNIQUE ROLE OF THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE.
ONE OF OUR FINALLY WERE ARE
GOING TO DISCUSS IN MORE DETAIL
TO THE SECOND PART OF TODAY'S
HEARING THE GOP SEES
RESPONSIBILITY WITH REGARD TO
APPOINTING THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S.
AND OVERSEEING THE LA ELS OFFICE
THE JAILBC MOST RECENTLY
CARRIED OUT THIS RESPONSIBILITY
BY UNANIMOUSLY APPOINTING
GABRIEL ADDICT.
WHO IS HERE WITH US TODAY AS OUR
NEW LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S THAT
APPOINTMENT WAS MADE IN JANUARY
WE APPOINTED MR PANIC AFTER AN
EXTENSIVE NATIONWIDE SEARCH?
LED BY A BIPARTISAN BY CARAMEL
SUBCOMMITTEE THAT I APPOINTED.
THE SUBCOMMITTEE WAS CRUCIAL --
BECAUSE MOST OF THIS WORK WAS
DONE DURING OUR LAST LEGISLATIVE
INTERIM SELL THE SUBCOMMITTEE
WISHES.
TO THANKS TO ALL OF YOU YOU'RE
WELCOME FOR HAVING THAT PULLED
YOU INTO OUR EXTENSIVE WORK
DURING YOUR INNER --
PERSON TO SERVE IN THIS ROLE IN
THE SEVENTY SEVEN YEAR HISTORY
OF THE LA JOH.
I'D LIKE TO THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS TEEN AND OBERNOLTE AND
SENATOR NIELSEN FOR SERVING WITH
ME ON THE SUBCOMMITTEE.
MY EXPECTATION IS THAT THE
SUBCOMMITTEE IN THIS ENTIRE
COMMITTEE WILL REMAIN ACTIVE IN
SUPPORTING OUR NEW HIGHER ODDS
IT IN SUPPORTING HIS SUCCESS IN
SERVICE TO THE LEGISLATION TO
THE CITIZENS OF CALIFORNIA --
VERTICALLY IN THIS FIRST
CRITICAL FIRST YEAR OF HIS
SERVICE.
WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO INVITE THE
VICE CHAIR ASSEMBLY MEMBER TEAM
TO MAKE ANY OPENING REMARKS
YOU'D LIKE.
TO SENATOR NIELSEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OBERNOLTE IF YOU WANT TO
GIVE ANY OPENING REMARKS BASED
ON YOUR EXPERIENCE WITH REGARD.
TO OUR WORK THIS --
DURING THE INTERIM AND AFTER
THAT WILL MOVE INTO THE
ORGANIZATIONAL COMPONENT OF OUR
HEARING.
VICE CHAIR TING.
THANK YOU SO MUCH ON THAT LET ME
ALSO JUST THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP --
WHAT SENATOR MITCHELL LEFT OUT
AS MOST OF THE INTERVIEWS AND
MEETINGS WERE RIGHT BEFORE THE?
HOLIDAY BREAK IN DECEMBER SO IT
WAS A WE WERE RIGHT THERE DOWN
TO THE WIRE AND REALLY
APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S TIME AND
EFFORT AND THIS FABULOUS
SUBCOMMITTEE.
ON THE DURING THIS SEARCH GO
ONLINE AND ACTUALLY REVIEW WHAT
THE MISSION OF THE ORGANIZATION
LAWS I THINK THAT.
THE THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S IS
AN ORGANIZATION THAT IS FRANKLY
TREASURED.
NOT ONLY IN SACRAMENTO NOT ONLY.
IN THE IN THIS BUILDING BUT ALSO
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY BECAUSE
IT'S ALSO THE AGENCY THAT THE
CONGRESSIONAL BUDGET OFFICE IS
MODELED AFTER SO.
IT'S INCREDIBLY HIGH PRAISE WHEN --
WASHINGTON DC DECIDES TO MODEL
THIS ORGANIZATION AFTER ONE OF
THEIR OWN AND IN REVIEWING THEIR
IN REVIEWING THEIR MISSION JUST
STRAIGHT FROM THE WEBSITE IT
SAYS OFFICERS AS THE EYES AND
EARS FOR THE LEGISLATURE. TO
ENSURE THAT THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH
IS IMPLEMENTING LEGISLATIVE
POLICY IN A COST EFFICIENT AND
EFFECTIVE.
MANNER.
I IN THE OFFICE IS KNOWN FOR ITS
FISCAL AND PROGRAM AND EXPERTISE
IN NONPARTISAN ANALYSIS OF THE
STATE BUDGET.
IN WHAT WE WHAT WE HAVE HIGHLY
VALUED.
AS A LEGISLATURE IS SO I THINK
THE HIGHLY COMPETENT STAFF THE
VERY EXCELLENT ANALYSIS OF WHAT.
REALLY HAS BEEN PRODUCED OVER
THE NUMBER YEARS HOWEVER I WAS
ACTUALLY.
SHOCKED TO FIND OUT THAT THE LA --
ACTUALLY REPORTS TO JAIL BC I
DID YEAH BECAUSE EVERYBODY'S
GOING. TO FIFTEENTH CHAIR AND
VICE CHAIR WHEN YOU'RE VICE
CHAIR YOU DON'T REALLY GET TO
KNOW AS MUCH TEXAS --
THAT'S ALSO WHAT I WOULD THINK I
FOUND OUT --
TO BUT YOU KNOW IT.
DATE OUR DISCUSSIONS AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU KNOW
CENTER MITCHELL CENTER NIELSEN
THIS YOU KNOW MY COLLEAGUE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OBERNOLTE.
I THINK WHAT WHAT YOU FOUND WAS
JUST THIS COMMITMENT FROM BOTH
THE ASSEMBLY AND THE SENATE THAT
WE REALLY WOULD LOVE OFFICE. TO
BE WORKING MORE CLOSELY WITH US
TO ACTUALLY HAVE A MORE POLICY
DIALOGUE POLICY --
SORT OF POLICY THINK WITH THE
THINKING THAT IS REALLY GOING ON
BECAUSE I THINK THERE'S BEEN A
FEELING THAT ANALYSIS.
HAS BEEN STUNNED SOMEONE IN IT
IN A VACUUM.
AND THAT THE ANALYSISBALL
EXCELLENT --
COMES OUT AND IT'S SORT OF
QUESTION LIKE --
WELL WE'RE WE'RE THAT REPORT
COME FROM OR WHAT CURIOUS WHY
THEY'RE LOOKING AT THIS.
YEAH I THINK THAT'S REALLY WHY
WE'RE HERE DAYS REALLY TRY A NEW
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S WITH THE
OFFICE.
TRYING TO DEVELOP --
KIND OF A A LONGER TERM WORK
PLAN WORKING RELATIONSHIP THAT
WE CAN KIND OF WORK IN SYNC
OBVIOUSLY THE ANALYSIS IS
EXCELLENT WE REALLY I THINK.
YOU KNOW THE THING SENATOR
NIELSEN NOT TO STEAL FROM HIS
THUNDER WAS WAS ALMOST WE'RE
GRATEFUL THAT WE YOU KNOW HE
DOESN'T HAVE TIME AND WE DON'T
ALL HAVE TIME TO READ ALL THIS
GREAT ANALYSIS NOW WE FEEL.
IN SOME WAYS WE WOULD WE WOULD
ALL BENEFIT FROM THIS I THINK IS
REALLY TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW
TO GET THE INFORMATION IN THE
RIGHT FORM.
SO THAT WE CAN DIGEST IT AND NOW
WE CAN REALLY GREATER.
GREATER USE IT BUT THERE'S NO
QUESTION THAT I LEAVE BEFORE OF
US THAT THIS BODY COMPLETELY.
TREASURES THE LA NOW IT'S REALLY
JUST MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE IN
GREATER SINK AND GREATER
DIALOGUE WITH THIS VERY
IMPORTANT ORGANIZATION. THIRTY
WILL SEND.
THAT MEANT CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR
AND IT WAS A PLEASURE WORKING
TOGETHER WITH YOU.
AND ONE OF THE MOST CRITICAL
THINGS ABOUT THIS.
IMPORTANT OFFICE IS THE
INTEGRITY.
THE INDEPENDENCE OF THE AVAIL.
OTHER COMMITTEES BUT NOT SO.
THE STUDIOS ARE BOUND
NECESSARILY BUT THIS ONE IS AND
THAT'S WHY IT'S BEEN REVERED
OVER THE DECADES.
NO SMALL REASON WHY IT
LEADERSHIP HAS BEEN SO STABLE
AND LONG TENURE.
AND OUR DESIRE STICK TO KEEP IT
IN THAT RESPECT AND THEN I WOULD
OFFERED THAT.
IF THERE'S ANY.
OLD REMISS IT'S ON THE PART OF
THE LEGISLATORS THEMSELVES NOT
GETTING ACQUAINTED WITH THE LA --
AND WHAT YOU DO.
AND IN FACT.
PANEL ICING IN REVIEWING SOME OF
THOSE MARVELOUS DOCUMENTS YOU
PUT OUT.
THEN I'D SAY MYSELF INCLUDED.
IT DID AND I'M ALWAYS TRYING TO
MAKE SURE THEY KEEP THOSE ON MY
DESK SO I AM TEMPTED.
TO FINISH AND READ THOSE VERY
IMPORTANT DOCUMENTS OF AND AND
IT HAS BEEN A GREAT CREDIT
MISSION AND THIS REPUTATION THAT
WE HAVE HAD THE LEGEND MOST OVER
THE YEARS AND IT WAS A GREAT
PLEASURE WORKING TOGETHER WITH
MY COLLEAGUES HERE --
YOU KNOW WHEN PEOPLE CRITICIZE
THE LEGISLATURE FOR BEING TOO
PARTISAN YOU THEN YOU SHOULD BUT
WATCHED THE WORK OF THE FOR A
MEMBERS THAT WERE ON THAT REVIEW
COMMITTEE.
AND HOW WE WORK TOGETHER SO WELL
AND SO UNANIMOUSLY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND I'D
LIKE TO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THE
SUBCOMMITTEE I THOUGHT THAT YOU
DID AN EXEMPLARY JOB AND KEEPING
THIS COMMITTEE.
ALIGNED AND MOVING IN THE SAME
DIRECTION AND I AM EXTREMELY
PROUD THAT WE WERE ABLE TO REACH
A UNANIMOUS CONCLUSION ON THE
DECISION TO HIRE.
MR PRODUCT I SHARE MY COLLEAGUES
OPTIMISM IN THE FUTURE OF OF THE
LA -- I ALSO
THINK I SPEAK FOR THE ENTIRE
SUBCOMMITTEE WHEN I SAY THAT WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE A CLOSER
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE ALEJO.
AND NOT ONLY JUST THE JAIL BC
BUT THE ENTIRE LEGISLATURE.
WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE MORE FISCAL
ANALYSIS BE DONE ON BILLS
OUTSIDE THE PURVIEW OF THE
BUDGET WHICH IS WHAT THE ONLY --
USED TO DO BEFORE THE PASSAGE OF
PROP ONE FORTY IN NINETEEN
NINETY ONE THE BUDGET OF THE LA --
WAS CUT I THINK THERE WOULD BE A
VERY HELPFUL THING. TO HAPPEN
THE LEGISLATURE I ALSO THINK
THAT THE ONLY --
HAS THE POTENTIAL FOR BEING THE
THINK TANK FOR THE LEGISLATURE.
YOU LOOK AT SOME OF THE REALLY
BIG SYSTEMIC THINGS LIKE.
PERVASIVE POVERTY AND
HOMELESSNESSAND THE HIGH COST
OF HOUSING AND BUSINESS FLIGHT
ALL OF THESE THINGS.
THERE WHAT THE LITERATURE IN
SOCIAL PSYCHOLOGY BECAUSE WE
COULD PROBLEMS AND WE IN THE
LEGISLATURE.
GET SOMETIME SO HEADS DOWN
PREPARING TO FOR VOTES ON THE
THOUSANDS OF BILLS THAT --
THAT COME THROUGH OUR DESKS.
THAT WE SOMETIMES LOSE SIGHT OF
THE BIG PICTURE AND I THINK THE
ONLY -- HAS
THAT OPPORTUNITY TO BECOME THE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT AND IT KIND
OF LOOKS AT THE BIG PICTURE AND
COMES UP WITH.
A CREATIVE SOLUTIONS TO SOME OF
THOSE PROBLEMS AND SHARES WITH
THE LEGISLATURE SO I'M I'M
EXTREMELY EXCITED ABOUT WORKING
WITH THE LA --
MOVING FORWARD LIKE TO THINK
MADAM CHAIR YOURSELF AND THE
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE FOR
THEIR DILIGENCE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH COLLEAGUES
IT WAS INDEED MY PLEASURE TO
WORK WITH YOU I THINK WE FELL
SHORT IN ONLY ONE AREA AND
THAT'S THE FACT THAT WE MISSED
PRONOUNCE MR BUT HEADACHES NAME
DURING OUR ENTIRE PROCESS WE
SPENT THE ENTIRE PROCESS.
CALLING HIM MISTER PATEK AND SO
IF YOU SEE ME HICK UP AS I SAY
IS NAME IS BECAUSE I'VE GOT TO
GET THE THE WRONG.
FOR NOT IT MIGHT BE AT A REPLACE
IT THAT WILL HOW DID STELLAR
WORK AND I THANK YOU --
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE INTO THE
ORGANIZATIONAL COMPLAIN OF THE
HEARING IN THE ADOPTION OF
COMMITTEE RULES.
ON THE COMMITTEE LAST ADAPTED
RULES IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND
THERE'S NO SUBSTANTIVE CHANGES
TO THE RULES BEFORE US TODAY
THEY CAN BE FOUND ON PAGES THREE
TO FOUR OF YOUR BACKGROUND
DOCUMENT COLLEAGUES.
IF YOU HAD A CHANCE TO REVIEW
THEM I'LL ASK FOR A MOTION ON
THE RULES.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR MITCHELL BY [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
MINING [inaudible]
NIELSEN I PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING [inaudible]
ARAMBULA [inaudible]
BLOOM MELENDEZ OBERNOLTE
[inaudible]
WEBER.
THE MAJOR CARRIERS THE RULES
CARRIER [inaudible] SIX AND FIVE
OF THE NEAR THE MEASURE KERRY'S.
FIVE ZERO SENATE MEMBERS FIVE
ZERO ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S.
NEXT -- WILL
BE THE MATTER OF ELECTION OF THE
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR --
HISTORICALLY BECAUSE THIS IS A
FISCAL COMMITTEE WITH
RESPONSIBILITIES RELATED TO THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE NAKED
BUDGET IT'S BEEN A LONG STANDING
TRADITION THAT THE CHAIR OF THE
SENATE BUDGET COMMITTEE SERVICE
CHAIR OF THE JAIL BC.
AND THE CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET COMMITTEE SERVE AS VICE
CHAIR OF THE JAIL BC IS THERE A
MOTION FOR ELECTION OF THE CHAIR.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
THAT THE CHAIR OF THE SENATE
BUDGET COMMITTEE WILL CONTINUE
TO SERVICE CHAIR OF THE GOP SEE.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR MITCHELL.
I FAITH MONNING [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STONE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING ARE
ARAMBULA.
BLOOM [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ OBERNOLTE.
REVERSE [inaudible]
WEBER.
THAT MOTION CARRIES UNANIMOUSLY
WITH ALL MEMBERS PRESENT VOTING --
IS THERE A MOTION FOR ELECTION
OF THE VICE CHAIR OF THE JAIL BC.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
MITCHELL BY.
BATES MONNING [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
CAN.
GEN TINA.
SKINNER.
STONE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING.
ARAMBULA [inaudible]
BLOOM [inaudible]
MCCARTY [inaudible]
MELENDEZ OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
RIVERSIDE [inaudible]
WEBER.
THAT MEASURE ALSO CARRIES IS --
PASSED UNANIMOUSLY --
BASED ON ALL THE MEMBERS PRESENT
VOTING HIGH NEXT COLLEAGUES WILL
MOVE ON TO ITEM THREE ARE ON OUR
ORGANIZATIONAL HERE IN OVERSIGHT
OF THE LA ELS AGENDA OVERVIEW
THE JAY I'LL BE FREE --
AS MY COLLEAGUE --
MISTER TING MENTIONED AS WE
BEGAN TO DO OUT REACH.
OUT TO JAIL BC MEMBERS ONCE WE
LEARNED OF THE RETIREMENT OF THE
FORMER ALEJO --
WE HAD SEVERAL MEMBERS SAY THEY
WERE RESPONSIBLE HAVE OVERSIGHT
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE OF THE LA
NOW.
I'M STILL A PART OF OUR
COMMITMENT WE MAKE TO EACH OTHER
DURING THE SELECTION PROCESS WAS
TO CONVENE THIS HEARING EARLY IN
THE YEAR YEAR NOT JUST TO DEAL
WITH THE ORGANIZATIONAL --
REQUIREMENTS OF THE STAB RESELL
TO THE COMMITTEE BUT ALSO GO A
LITTLE DEEPER IN TERMS OF THE
ROLE THE JB JAIL BC.
AND OUR RELATIONSHIP --
AS REPRESENTED AT THE FULL
LEGISLATURE WITH THE LA OUT.
SO A LITTLE BACKGROUND THE
LEGISLATURE ESTABLISH A JAIL B.
C. IN NINETEEN FORTY ONE AT THE
SAME TIME THEY CREATED THE LA L.
AROUND THAT TIME CALIFORNIA
SURPLUS FOR THE FIRST TIME AFTER
A DECADE OF DEFICITS THAT SOUNDS
FAMILIAR.
THEN GOVERNOR ALL SET IN THE
LEGISLATURE IT WERE IN CONFLICT
OVER THE STATE BUDGET AND THE
LEGISLATURE DETERMINE IT WANTED
ITS OWN SOURCE OF INFORMATION
FREE FROM THE CONTROL OR
INFLUENCE OF THE ADMINISTRATION.
THIS DESIRE FOR INDEPENDENT
INFORMATION FOR THE CREATION OF
BOTH THE JAIL B. C.AS WELL AS
THE LEDGE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
SO TODAY THE JAIL BC HAVE THREE
PRIMARY RESPONSIBILITIES.
THE FIRST IS TO REVIEW ON BEHALF
OF THE LEGISLATURE CHANGES OR
OTHER ACTIONS THE ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSALS RELATE PROPOSES
RELATED TO A BUDGET THAT HAS
ALREADY BEEN ENACTED.
THE JAIL BC.
RECEIVED APPROXIMATELY TWO
HUNDRED OR MORE OF THESE
NOTIFICATIONS FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION ALL YEAR LONG.
PROPOSED CHANGES RANGE FROM
EXPENDED A SMALL AMOUNT OF ON
ANTICIPATED FEDERAL FARMS TO
TRANSFER IN BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
FROM THE STATE'S RESERVES IN
RESPONSE TO AN EMERGENCY.
THE CHART ON PAGE TWO OF YOUR
BACKGROUND --
GIVES --
SUMMARIZES SOME OF THE MOST
COMMON NOTICES WE RECEIVE.
THE LA OVERSEAS THESE NOTICES AS
WELL AND THE LA L. OFTEN
PROVIDES A WRITTEN ANALYSIS
RELATED TO THE NOTIFICATION.
ALL JAIL BC MEMBERS RECEIVE A
COPY OF THE LA ELS ANALYSIS OF
THESE REQUESTS.
IN MOST INSTANCES THE LACK OF
RESPONSE IN THE GOP SEE MEANS
THE PROPOSED ACTION WILL
AUTOMATICALLY TAKE EFFECT.
ON BEHALF OF THE COMMITTEE
HOWEVER I MAY RESPOND AS CHAIR
TO THE NOTIFIED ENTITY THIS
USUALLY FALLS COLLABORATION
ACROSS THE HOUSES --
AT INCLUDES ADMINISTRATION AND
INFORMING THE RESPONSE COMMITTEE
STAFF ALSO SEND COPIES OF ANY
LETTERS THAT THE CHAIR SINCE THE
ALL COMMITTEE MEMBERS SO YOU ARE
INFORMED.
AND OUT --
REEMPHASIZE THAT THE LETTERS
COME THROUGHOUT THE COURSE OF
THE YEAR.
IT SEEMS PRIMARILY THROUGH INTO
A DURING THE INTERIM I'M JUST
SAYING BUT THEY DO GO TO YOUR
OFFICE EVEN IF YOU DON'T SEE
THEM ON A REGULAR BASIS.
THE SECOND GOP SEE
RESPONSIBILITY I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT IS THAT WE RECEIVING
REVIEW ANYWHERE FROM TWO TO
THREE HUNDRED REPORTS FROM
AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF STATE PROGRAMS.
COMMITTEE STAFF DISTRIBUTE THESE
REPORTS THROUGHOUT THE YEAR TO
ALL DEAL BC MEMBER OFFICES AND
IN RECENT YEARS WITH --
OUR NEW STAFF TO THE COMMITTEE
THEY'VE BEEN VERSUS PAPER
VERSION. TWO EXAMPLES OF THESE
REPORTS WOULD BE AN REPORTS ON
THE STATUS OF A MAJOR AUTOMATION
PROJECT OR MONTHLY REPORTS FROM
THE DMV ON THEIR RECENT WAIT
TIMES THOSE ARE JUST TWO
EXAMPLES.
OF THE TWO TO THREE HUNDRED
PORTS THAT COM.
THE FINAL RESPONSIBILITY THE IBC
IS AGAIN THAT WE SELECT THE LEAD
TO ALICE AND OVERSEE THE LA L..
AS I MENTIONED EARLIER AFTER A
BIPARTISAN BICAMERAL SEARCH THIS
FALL THE DEAL BE SEE APPOINTED
MISTER PECK TO THIS POSITION IN
JANUARY.
BEFORE WE MOVE INTO THE SECOND
PART OF OUR HEARING IN WHICH WE
WILL TALK FURTHER ABOUT THE GOP
SEES ROLE WITH RESPECT TO THE LA
OUT.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
ABOUT THE GOP SEES FUNCTIONS
ITSELF.
SEEING NONE WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
INTO THE SECOND PART ON AND I'D
LIKE TO INVITE.
MISTER PANIC TO COME FORWARD AND
JOIN US AT THE TABLE.
AGAIN WOULD PUT.
TODAY'S CONVERSATION IN A LITTLE
BIT MORE CONTEXT MR TING ALLUDED
TO IT DURING THE SEARCH THIS
FALL WITH THE SUBCOMMITTEE HAD
EXTENSIVE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
THE ROLE OF THE LA ALL ITS
RESOURCES.
AND HOW THE JAIL BC CAN BEST
CARRY OUT OUR DUTIES TO OVERSEE
THE LA OUT.
WHEN THE RESULT OF OUR DIALOGUE
WITH THE BIPARTISAN INTRODUCTION
OF ACA ELEVEN WHICH WOULD REMOVE
THE LA L. FROM THE LEGISLATURE
SPENDING CAP UNDER PROP ONE
FORTY AND POTENTIALLY ALLOW FOR
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT IN THE
OFFICE?
WITH THAT CAP IN PLACE THE LA L.
STAFF HAS NOT BEEN ABLE TO GROW
IN TANDEM WITH THE GROWTH IN THE
SIZE AND COMPLEXITY OF THE STATE
BUDGET.
AND SO AS WE TALK ABOUT OUR
EXPECTATIONS OF THIS INDEPENDENT
THIRD PARTY.
NONPARTISAN THINK TANK WE HAVE A
RESPONSE REALLY RESOURCE THEY
HAVE THE STAFF IN PLACE TO DO
THE KIND OF JOB WE FIND THE
VALUE.
AGAIN ANOTHER RESULT OF OUR
DIALOGUE WAS A COMMITMENT TO
CONVNE THIS HEARING ULTIMATELY
WE WANT THIS DISCUSSION TO HELP
INSURE THAT AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE
THERE IS A PROCESS FOR ENSURING
AN ONGOING ALIGNMENT.
BETWEEN WHAT THE LEGISLATURE
NEEDS FROM THE ALEJO AND HOW THE
LA --
PRIORITIZES ITS RESOURCES WITH
THAT I'LL ASK MISTER PETTIT
OFFERS PRESENTATION TO BEGIN
THIS PART OF THE HEARING.
GOOD MORNING AND THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US AND WELCOME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR.
VICE CHAIR AND MEMBERS FOR
INVITING ME HERE TODAY.
IT'S A REAL HONOR FOR ME TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE HEARING AND
SO AS A WE THE CHAIR JUST SAID
MY NAME IS GAY PADDICK.
AND I AM THE RECENTLY APPOINTED
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST.
I STARTED ABOUT SIX WEEKS AGO.
AND SO IF YOU DON'T MIND I'D
LIKE TO JUST DIG KNOWLEDGE THAT
MY COLLEAGUES THE DEPUTY
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S HAVE
ACCOMPANIED ME OVER HERE TODAY
IN OUR ADMINISTRATIVE OFFICER.
AND I HAD ALSO --
IT'S OKAY LIKE TO MENTION THAT
THEY'VE REALLY THEY'VE GONE
ABOVE AND BEYOND IN EQUITY ME
WITH THE OFFICE.
AND THE NUANCES OF OUR ROLE AND
I HAVE REALLY --
AND MADE IT A SMOOTHER
TRANSITION THAN YOU COULD
IMAGINE IN PARTICULAR I WANTED
TO THANK CAROLINE CHU WHO SERVED
IN THE POSITION OF THE INTERIM
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S BEFORE I
ARRIVED ON THE SCENE SO --
THANK YOU TO HER.
BUT SO WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO DO
IF IT'S OKAY IS GO THROUGH AN
OVERVIEW OF OUR OFFICE INCLUDING
A BRIEF HISTORY WHICH YOU
ACTUALLY ALLUDED TO ALREADY.
MADAM CHAIR AND THEN DESCRIBE
FOR YOU ARE --
SUMMARY A SUMMARY OF OUR MAIN
FUNCTIONS HOW WE HAVE EXECUTED
ON THOSE.
HIGHLIGHT OUR STAFFING LEVELS
AND ORGANIZATIONAL STRUCTURE AND
THEN DESCRIBE FOR YOU THE AND
WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO PRESENT AS
MY PRIORITIES FOR THE COMING
TWELVE MY SO WE CAN TRACE THE
HISTORY OF OUR OFFICE BACK TO
THE NINETEEN THIRTIES.
A TIME WHEN THE THE STATE BUDGET
WAS BECOMING MORE COMPLEX.
AND IN THAT.
THE LEGISLATURE HAD BECOME
CONCERNED ABOUT THE BALANCE OF
POWER BETWEEN IT IN THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH.
AND SO AS THE CHAIR MENTIONED
THE OP THE THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED LEGISLATION THAT WOULD
ESTABLISH WHAT WAS THEN CALLED
THE LEGISLATIVE AUDITORS OFFICE
IN.
NINETEEN FORTY ONE ONLY TO HAVE
IT VETOED BY THEN GOVERNOR
COLBERT WILSON.
BUT THE LEGISLATURE WAS
UNDETERRED AND STE WHEN I HAD AN
ESTABLISHED OUR OFFICE THROUGH A
JOINT RULE BETWEEN THE SENATE
AND THE ASSEMBLY.
AND I DO THINK IT IS A YOU KNOW
TESTAMENT TO THE VALUE OF THE
FUNCTION OF OUR OFFICE THAT NOW
ALL FIFTY STATES HAVE SOME
VERSION OF THE LEGISLATIVE
FISCAL OFFICE.
AND AS MR TING MENTIONED THAT
THE OFFICE IS THE MODEL THAT THE
CONGRESSIONAL BUDGET BUDGET
OFFICE WAS --
BASED ON SO OUR OUR MISSION AS A
PURSUANT TO THE JOINT RULE THAT
WE WERE ESTABLISHED UNDER IS TO
ASCERTAIN FACTS AND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
LEGISLATURE ON MATTERS
CONCERNING THE BUDGET.
NEWS AND EXPENDITURES THE
ORGANIZATION AND FUNCTIONS OF
STATE GOVERNMENT ITS DEPARTMENTS
SUBDIVISIONS AND AGENCIES SO I
THINK A SUMMARY WAY TO SAY THAT
IS JUST THAT WE HAVE A BROAD BUT
PHYSICALLY ORIENTED MANDATE.
WE ARE ACCOUNTABLE TO THE JAIL
BC.
AND ONE OF THE MAIN WAYS THAT
YOU EXPRESSED THAT IS THROUGH
YOUR APPOINTMENT OF THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST IN THIS CASE
ME AND I SERVE AT THE PLEASURE
OF THE COMMITTEE.
WE VERY MUCH ARE A CREATION OF
THE LEGISLATURE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE.
SO MOVING ON TO THE SECOND PAGE
WHICH I SHOULD HAVE MENTIONED I
HOPE YOU HAVE A COPY OF THE HAND.
THERE.
AND ON THIS PAGE I THOUGHT I'D.
BRIEFLY DESCRIBE TO OUR
RESPNSIBILITIES ARE MAIN
RESPONSIBILITIES I THINK YOU CAN
PUT THEM INTO THREE BROAD
CATEGORIES ONE IS OUR BUDGET
ANALYSIS THE SECOND IS.
OUR OTHER LEGISLATIVE WORK AND
THEN THIRD OUR OUR DUTIES AS IT --
WITH REGARD TO BUDGET MEASURES
AND ANALYSIS.
SO.
HONOR BUDGET RESPONSIBILITIES
ROLL IS NOTABLE FOR
TRADITIONALLY INITIATING THE
ANNUAL --
THIS BUDGET CYCLE WHEN WE
RELEASE OUR FISCAL FORECAST EACH
NOVEMBER.
AND THEN OUR WORK ON THE BUDGET
CONTINUES IN JANUARY FOLLOWING
RELEASE OF THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL.
ABOUT WHICH WE PROVIDE AN
ASSESSMENT MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS
PROVIDE ALTERNATIVE
CONSIDERATIONS FOR THE AND M.
PROVIDE CAN ALTERNATIVE
CONSIDERATIONS FOR THE
LEGISLATURE.
WE ALSO HAVE A AN IMPORTANT
CONTROL FUNCTION WITH REGARD TO
THE BUDGET.
WE RUN INDEPENDENT CALCULATIONS
OF THE VARIOUS STATE FUNDING
FORMULAS AND WE ANALYZE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S CALCULATIONS IN
THIS AREA.
AND AS YOU JUST DISCUSSED IN THE
FIRST --
PORTION OF THIS HEARING WE ALSO
REVIEW ALL OF THE SPENDING
REQUEST TO COME OVER FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION AFTER THE BUDGET
HAS BEEN ENACTED.
MOVING TO OUR OTHER LEGISLATIVE
RESPONSIBILITIES I WILL
HIGHLIGHT JUST A COUPLE OF THESE
ITEMS FOR YOU.
I CAN SEE ALREADY FROM MY TIME
IN THE OFFICE THAT ONE OF OUR
MAIN FOCUSES IS RESPONDING TO
QUESTIONS AND REQUESTS THAT COME
IN FROM THE MEMBERS AND THEIR
STAFFS [inaudible]
SO.
YOU KNOW THESE CAN RANGE FROM
LESS FORMAL PHONE CALLS AND
EMAILS WHERE --
STAFF MEMBERS TYPICALLY WILL
CALL UP WITH A QUESTION --
SEEKING CERTAIN DATA AND OUR
STAFF WILL.
SEE TO TRY TO PROVIDE THAT TO
THEM -- BUT
OTHER TIMES THE REQUESTS ARE
MORE FORMAL AND COME AT IN A
LETTER FROM THE FROM MEMBERS
THEMSELVES ASKING US TO EVALUATE
THE POTENTIAL IMPACT OF SOME
POLICY PROPOSAL THAT THEY'RE
CONSIDERING.
AND SO THEN THE OTHER ONE I
WANTED TO JUST MENTION HERE IS
THE FOURTH BULLET POINT IN THIS
CATEGORY WHERE IT SAYS STUDY NEW
POLICY IDEAS.
SO THIS IS REALLY WHERE WE WOULD
INITIATE AT OUR OWN DISCRETION
TAKING A DEEPER LOOK AT A
CERTAIN POLICY ISSUE OR A
PROBLEM THAT WE HAVE IDENTIFIED
IN THE COURSE OF DOING OUR OTHER
WORK.
NOW HOPEFULLY IN EVEN ALLUDED TO
IT ALREADY BUT HOPEFULLY IN MY
GOAL IS FOR THIS TO BE.
RELEVANT TO YOU.
HELLO ALIGNED WITH THE NEEDS OF
THE LEGISLATURE AND TIMELY SO
FOR EXAMPLE IN SEPTEMBER WE
RELEASED A REPORT CALLED --
IMPROVING FORESTRY MANAGEMENT
NOW THAT WAS DONE IN YOU KNOW IN
THE AFTERMATH OF THE DEVASTATING
WILDFIRES THAT IT STRUCK THE
STATE OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS --
SO THEN YOU KNOW MOVING TO THE
FINAL CATEGORY ON THIS PAGE IT
IS OUR BALLOT RESPONSIBILITIES.
THIS IS A DUTY OF OURS PURSUANT
TO THE POLITICAL REFORM ACT OF
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR I THINK
THIS ONE IS INTERESTING BECAUSE
OF ALL OF OUR RESPONSIBILITIES.
THIS IS ONE WHERE WE ARE NOT
EXPLICITLY SERVING THE
LEGISLATURE RATHER WERE SERVING
THE ONE OF THE OTHER MAJOR
POLICY MAKING BODIES IN THE
STATE THE VOTERS THEMSELVES.
SO UNDER THE POLITICAL REFORM
ACT OF NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR WE
ARE CHARGED WITH.
PROVIDING AN IMPARTIAL ANALYSIS
OF VOTER INITIATIVES AND AND
WHEN THEY MAKE IT TO THE BALLOT.
WE PROVIDE A SUMMARY ANALYSIS.
OF THE ANALYSIS IS IT A FISCAL
IMPACT ASSESSMENT SO WHAT IS THE
FISCAL IMPACT OF THE INITIATIVE
ON US ON THE STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS.
AND ALSO A SUMMARY WRITTEN IN
PLAIN LANGUAGE THAT VOTERS CAN
UNDERSTAND OF WHAT IT YES OR NO
VOTE MIGHT MEAN IN THAT CASE.
OKAY SO MOVING TO PAGE.
THREE HERE IS THE WAY TO THINK
ABOUT THIS SLIDE IS REALLY THIS
IS HOW WE DELIVER ON THE
RESPONSIBILITIES THAT I JUST
MENTIONED ON THE PREVIOUS PAGE.
WE DELIVER IN TWO MAIN WAYS PULL
THROUGH A WRITTEN PRODUCTS BUT
THEN ALSO IN OUR OTHER TYPES OF
SUPPORT FOR THE LEGISLATURE FEES
THE OTHER TYPES WHICH I'LL JUST
MENTION HERE QUICKLY.
ARE LISTED AT THE BOTTOM BUT
THEIR YOU KNOW TO PROVIDING A
TESTIMONY THAT HEARINGS.
SUPPORTING YOUR STAFF'S AS YOU
DEVELOP THE AS THEY DEVELOP THE
AGENDA IS FOR THE HEARINGS
THROUGHOUT THE BUDGET CYCLE.
AND JUST PROVIDING A GENERAL
RESOURCE TO YOU THROUGHOUT THE
YEAR AT ANY POINT WE ALSO FIELD
AND RESPOND TO QUESTIONS FROM
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS IN THE
LEGISLATIVE AND BUDGET PROCESS
AND WE THINK OF THAT IS
HOPEFULLY A SERVICE TO YOU.
AS WELL.
UP ABOVE I HAVE PROVIDED A TABLE
TO USE THAT TALLIES THE KEPT
DIFFERENT CATEGORIES OF THE
WRITTEN PRODUCTS THAT OUR OFFICE
HAS PRODUCED OVER THE LAST TWO
YEARS.
I WOULD LIKE TO DRY YOUR
ATTENTION TO THE FOOTNOTE AND
THE TOP ONE IN PARTICULAR.
THIS IS --
AS THE CHAIR MENTIONED WE WOULD
RESPOND.
TO SOME OF THE REQUESTS --
FORWARD SPENDING AUTHORITY
OUTSIDE OF THE BUDGET PROCESS
THROUGH --
THAT COME IN THROUGH THESE
BUDGET NOTIFICATION LETTERS.
BUT WE REALLY ONLY GOING TO
RAISE.
A FLAG OR A POINTED OUT TO YOU
AND IT WITH A WRITTEN RESPONSE
IN TIMES AND WE THINK THAT THE
REQUEST IS INCONSISTENT WITH
PREVIOUS LEGISLATIVE ACTION OR
THERE'S SOMETHING QUESTIONABLE
ABOUT THE TIMING OF IT.
MEANING THIS SEEMS LIKE IT COULD
BE SO WITH DURING THE REGULAR
BUDGET PROCESS SOMETHING LIKE
THAT.
SO -- THAT'S
I JUST WANTED TO POINT THAT OUT
ANOTHER OBSERVATION ABOUT THIS
TABLE IS WHAT IF YOU SAW THESE
NUMBERS OVER TIME OVER LONGER
THAN JUST A TWO YEAR PERIOD I
THINK WHAT YOU SEE IS WERE USING
MORE AND MORE.
OUR ECONOMY AND TAX BLOG AND
OTHER WEB POSTINGS.
SO I THINK THE THE TREND WILL BE
AND I WOULD LIKE TO CONTINUE IN
THIS DIRECTION.
PROVIDING SORT OF A REAL TIME
ANALYSIS OF THE PERFORMANCE OF
KEY ASPECTS OF THE STATE BUDGET
REVENUE COLLECTIONS --
EXPENDITURE TRENDS.
AND I THINK THIS PLATFORM IS
PROBABLY A GOOD WAY TO DO THAT
IN AN EFFICIENT MANNER.
AND THEN THE LAST THING I'LL
SPECIFICALLY MENTION ABOUT THIS
PAGE IS TO THE ONE CALLED OTHER
REPORTS.
NOW THIS IS WHERE.
THE THE REPORTS THAT WE DECIDE
WITHIN THE OFFICE WARRANT SENATE
DID SOME SOME ISSUE WARRANTS
ADDITIONAL RESEARCH IN THAT WE
SHOULD RIGHTS READ A REPORT
ABOUT IT.
AND SO YOU CAN SEE I WANTED TO
PROVIDE THIS TO GIVE YOU A SENSE
OF ALL OF OUR WRITTEN PRODUCTS.
A LITTLE BIT OF A FEEL.
FOR WHAT THE MAGNITUDE OF EACH
OF THESE CATEGORIES IS AND SO
HOPEFULLY THAT'S HELPFUL.
OKAY SO MOVING TO THE FOURTH
PAGE.
THIS SLIDE IS DESCRIPTION OF OUR
PERSONNEL AND MAY BE OF INTEREST
TO YOU.
CURRENTLY THE OFFICE HAS FORTY
ONE ANALYST WHICH INCLUDES THE
FOR DEPUTY ANALYSTS AND WE ALSO
HAVE THREE MANAGING PRINCIPAL
ANALYST.
THE OFFICE IS ORGANIZED INTO
FOUR SECTIONS EACH SECTION
MANAGED BY ONE OF THE DEPUTIES.
AND THE SECTIONS A LINE WITH THE
KEY AREAS OF THE STATE BUDGET SO
EDUCATION.
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES STATE
AND LOCAL FINANCE.
AND THE A SECTION THAT COVERS
THE CORRECTIONS TRANSPORTATION
AND ENVIRONMENT.
I WOULD LIKE TO SHARE WITH YOU
THAT AFTER HAVING BEEN THERE FOR
YOU KNOW THE SIX WEEKS.
I CAN TELL ALREADY THAT THERE'S
A VERY BIG EMPHASIS PUT ON
BRINGING NEW STAFF AND THE
YOUNGER NINOS LESS TENURED
ANALYSTS.
INTO A POSITION WHERE THEY ON
THE AREAS OF THE BUDGET THAT
THEY COVER.
THERE'S A VERY.
HIGH CAN SAY COMPARED WITH MY
PREVIOUS PROFESSIONAL EXPERIENCE
THEY HAVE A VERY ROBUST
ONBOARDING PROCESS AND I WAS
VERY PLEASED TO SEE THAT I THINK
IT.
SERVES YOU WELL I HOPE.
A AND THEN ON THE LAST PAGE I
THOUGHT I WOULD JUST HIGHLIGHT
FOR YOU A COUPLE OF MY TOP
PRIORITIES FOR THIS FIRST TWELVE
MONTHS OR SO.
I THINK THAT YOU MIGHT FIND THAT
THERE'S SOME ALIGNMENT WITH SOME
OF THE COMMENTS THAT --
HAVE BEEN MADE IN THE OPENING
REMARKS HERE.
BECAUSE THE FIRST ONE THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO DO IS EXPAND OUR
MEMBER AND STAFF COMMUNICATIONS.
NOW FOR ME WHAT THIS MEANS IS IN
THE FIRST PHASE REALLY JUST
SETTING UP OUTREACH MEETINGS TO
TRY TO MAKE SURE THAT I'VE MET
EACH OF YOU AND OTHER
LEGISLATORS.
AND SOME OF YOUR STAFF MEMBERS.
AND WHILE I THINK THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT I THINK THERE ISN'T A
RESPONSIBILITY.
OF THE PERSON IN MY SEAT TO NOT
JUST ESTABLISH THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS BUT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY ARE ROBUST AN ON GOING.
SO THAT'S JUST SORT OF THEFIRST
PHASE AND I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE A
A DIALOGUE WITH YOU IS WHAT I'M
TRYING TO SAY.
AND THE WAY THE ONE IMPORT IT
WOULD BE --
EXPERIENCED I THINK IS THROUGH
THE SECOND BULLET POINT HERE
WHICH IS. TO INCREASE OUR OUT
REACH PARTICULARLY DURING THE
PHASE WHEN WE ARE DEVELOPING A
RESEARCH AGENDA SO I'VE
MENTIONED A COUPLE TIMES
THROUGHOUT THIS THE PART ABOUT
WHERE WE HAVE SOME REPORTS THAT
WE DO ON A SELF INITIATED BASIS.
I WILL MAKE IT A PRIORITY OF MY
TENURE TO ENSURE THAT.
THOSE KIND OF RESEARCH REPORTS
ARE.
RELEVANT TO THE LEGISLATURE
THERE ARE TIMELY AND IMPORTANT
TO CALIFORNIA AND SO THAT'S JUST
ONE OF MY TOP PRIORITIES AND I
THINK WE'RE GOING --
TO KIND OF DO THAT BY HOPEFULLY
BRINGING OVER.
THE DEPUTIES ALONG WITH ME TO
ENGAGE IN A DISCUSSION SOME
BRAINSTORMING SESSIONS IF YOU
WILL JUST TO HAVE.
SO THE YOU HAVE AN IDEA OF WHAT
WE'RE THINKING ABOUT FOCUSING ON
AND HEAR FROM YOU WHAT YOUR
PRIORITIES ARE DIRECTLY.
ALTHOUGH I WOULD SAY AS AN ASIDE
I CAN TELL THAT OUR OUR STAFF
MEMBERS DO SEEM TO SPEND A LOT
OF TIME TRYING TO PAY ATTENTION
TO WHAT YOU WHAT.
YOU ARE FOCUSING ON THE OTHER
THIRD ONE HERE I WANTED TO
MENTION THAT I A HAVE.
REALIZED THAT THERE IS A NEED
FOR ME AND ALL OF ORGANIZATIONS
BUT IN MY MY JOB ONE THING I
WOULD LIKE TO DO.
IS SPEND TIME THIS YEAR TAKING A
CLOSE LOOK AT THE BASICALLY THE
LOOK AND FEEL OF OUR WORK
PRODUCTS.
AND ALSO OUR WEBSITE --
IN THIS DAY AND AGE THE METHODS
OF COMMUNICATION CHANGE QUICKLY
AND WE ARE IN CALIFORNIA AFTER
ALL THE THE HOME OF THE HIGH
TECH SECTOR SO IT'S IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US TO COMMUNICATE
IN MODERN METHODS AND THE AND
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE DELIVERING
OUR MESSAGE IN A WAY THAT.
PEOPLE RECEIVE INFORMATION AND
ANALYSIS IN THIS DAY AND AGE.
SO THEN THE LAST THING I WANTED
TO SAY HERE WAS JUST THAT.
ANOTHER --
PRIORITY OF MINE WOULD BE TO
LEVERAGE MY BACKGROUND AS A
FINANCIAL ANALYST THAT COVERED
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND THINK ABOUT SOME OF THOSE
BIGGER PICTURE ISSUES THOSE
TRENDS.
THAT --
BEYOND THINKING OF DEMOGRAPHIC
SOCIO ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENTS
MACRO ECONOMIC TRENDS AND HOW DO
THOSE.
DRIVES CALIFORNIA'S REVENUES AND
THERE AND IT'S EXPENDITURES TO
TRY TO HAVE AN IDEA OF WHAT THE
STATE'S LONGER TERM FISCAL
TRAJECTORY IS.
BOTH IF WE DO CERTAIN THINGS AND
IF WE DON'T DO CERTAIN THINGS SO.
IT IS THIS ONE IS --
WOULD BE SORT OF A AN IDEA THAT
COULD ACCOMPANY BASICALLY ARE.
CURRENTLY --
OUR OUR CURRENT FISCAL FORECAST
THAT WE PRODUCE EACH NOEMBER.
WOULD BE KIND OF TAKING A STEP
BACK AND LOOKING AT THE BIGGER
PICTURE.
SO THAT'S THE OVERVIEW AND WITH
THAT I AM HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU --
AS I DEVELOPED A LIST HERE IS
MEMBERS I SEE DOCTOR PAN.
LET ME KNOW --
THEY HAVE QUESTIONS BUT LET ME
JUST THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION --
AS MR TING AND I JUST WHISPERED
BACK AND FORTH TO EACH OTHER WE
FEEL HEARD --
IN TERMS OF SOME OF OUR INITIAL --
OUT WE CAN CONVERSATION WITH YOU
BUT VERSUS YOU KNOW WE'VE TALKED
A LOT ABOUT THE ISSUE OF
RESOURCES ARE THE SUBCOMMITTEE
DID IN.
AND MISTER OBERNOLTE --
BROUGHT FOR HIS PERSPECTIVE
ABOUT WHAT NEEDED TO BE CHANGED
IN WHICH IS MANIFESTED ACA.
ELEVEN BUT WHAT STRIKES ME
SITTING HERE ON BE REMINDED OF
THE RESPONSIBILITIES OF THE LA.
LA JOH ARE THE BALLOT MEASURE
RESPONSIBILITIES AND WHEN WE
CONSIDER THE CONSISTENT INCREASE
IN THE SHEER VOLUME THE SHEER
NUMBER OF BALLOT MEASURES THAT
ARE REFLECTED ON LITERALLY
THROUGHOUT.
EVERY.
ELECTION CYCLE I'M STRUCK THAT
THAT HASN'T BEEN TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION WITH A IT'S A
CONSIDERATION WITH REGARD TO
RESOURCES.
YOU KNOW I DON'T KNOW THE
POLITICAL REFORM ACT OF NINETEEN
SEVENTY FOUR ACKNOWLEDGING THAT.
I'M SURE THE POLITICAL REFORM
ACT OF NINETEEN SEVENTY THE FOUR
COULDN'T IMAGINE THAT IN TWENTY
NINETEEN WE WOULD --
BE GOVERNED QUITE TO THE DEGREE
THAT WE ARE --
THROUGH REFERENDUM SO THAT'S A
CONCERN PARTICULARLY WHEN WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT YOUSAY THAT
YOU'VE GOT AN OFFICE OF FORTY
ONE I WAS TRYING TO LOOK UP IN
THE BUDGET RIGHT QUICK TO TO GET
THE NUMBER.
IN A SENSE OF THE NUMBER AND
APARTMENT FIND OVERALL NUMBER
BUT JUST AS A COMPARISON IN
FINANCE THEY HAVE THIRTY SEVEN
IN MANAGEMENT ALONE.
AND SO I'LL GET YOU THE FULL
NUMBER AND IT'S NOT THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT A FIFTEEN PER FTE
COMPARISONS BUT JUST WHEN WE
CONSIDER.
THE SCOPE OF WORK BUT THE LA --
GAUGE THE IN --
THANK YOU MISTER OBERNOLTE FOR A
C. ELEVEN AND WE'RE GOING TO DO
ALL THAT WE CAN TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT ARE INDEPENDENT THINK
TANK.
IS APPROPRIATELY RESOURCE --
WE'LL START WITH DOCTOR PAIR
[inaudible]
AUSTIN'S.
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION AND I GUESS ONE OF
THE QUESTIONS I WANTED TO ASK
INTERNET AND APPRECIATE --
YOUR THE YEAR HERE OVERVIEW AND
SERVICE OUTLINING SOME OF THE
WAYS YOU SEE --
THAT DO YOU WANT CHANGE IN TERMS
OF ADDRESSING THE NEEDS OF THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE FACT THAT
YOU ALSO FUNCTIONING THIS FINES
FUNCTION FOR THE PUBLIC AS WELL
AND I ALSO WONDER WHETHER.
THE COST OF THAT SHOULD BE NOT
COUNTED AGAINST OUR LEGISLATIVE
LIMITS SINCE THIS ALTHOUGH YOU
ARE PART OF LEGISLATURE IN TERMS
OF YOUR FUNDING --
THAT BECAUSE THIS IS A SERVICE
OF THE PUBLIC BUT THAT'S A WHOLE
NOTHER CONVERSATION --
THE BUT WHY DID WANT TO ASK YOU
WAS IS THAT --
WHEN THINGS THAT AND I KNOW THAT
YOU'RE SERVE YOUR STAFF IS HEARD
FROM ME AND BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
I THINK US OUR MONEY JUST
STEPPED OUT ALSO --
THE SHARES WITH ME HAS SHARED
ITH THIS IS WELLS WHEN WE LOOK
AT A BUDGET ISSUES OR FINANCIAL
ISSUES WHETHER THINGS THAT WE
WANT TO LOOK AT IS.
OFTENTIMES THERE'S TRADE OFFS
RIGHT AND SO.
A PROGRAM WOULD BE BROUGHT
BEFORE US AND FINANCE WILL SAY
WILL COST A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF
MONEY BECAUSE THE ALL BOB
CERTAIN ABOUT STAFF AND SO FORTH
BUT THERE IS RESEARCH DATA
WILLING TO SET A VERY HIGH BAR
FOR THAT IT'S NOT JUST A QUITE
THINK IT'S GOING TO BUT IF.
YOU HAVE EVIDENCE BASED RESEARCH
CLASS -- YOU
KNOW OF STUDIES --
SPECIALLY --
EVEN CLINICAL TRIALS ARE THIS
INTERVENTION WOULD ACTUALLY DO
SO EXPENDITURES LATER ON THAT
THAT SHOULD BE REFLECTED IN OUR
ANALYSIS AND I BASICALLY BRING
THIS UP FOR L. A. L. BECAUSE
FINANCE WORKS FOR THE GOVERNOR
SO THAT'S THE GOVERNOR WILL HAVE
TO GIVE DIRECTION BUT AS OUR LA
YELLOW.
I'D LIKE TO SEE THAT KIND OF
CAPACITY IN THE LA --
SO AND AND FRANKLY I TELL THE
ADVOCATES WILL BRING THE
EVIDENCE TO THE ALEJO RIGHT SO
MY REALIZE YOU'RE NOT YOU KNOW
YOU'RE A LITTLE SHORT STAFFED
AND SO BRING WHAT YOU HAVE.
BUT I DO HOPE THAT THE LA --
CAN LOOK AT THE EVIDENCE.
IN ADDITION TO HOPEFULLY BE I'LL
DO A LITTLE OF YOUR OWN RESEARCH
BUT BUT AT LEAST LOOK AT AND SAY
WELL ACTUALLY IN THE OUT YEARS
WE SHOULD BE SCORING SAVINGS.
NOT JUST COSTS RIGHT BECAUSE
EASIEST CORE LIKE OF THIS GUN
REQUIRE EX NUMBER PEOPLE AT
CETERA AND DAYS AFTER IAN THAT'S
MONEY OUT BUT WHEN YOU HAVE
RESEARCH THAT SHOWS WELL
ACTUALLY PUTTING THOSE
INVESTMENTS AND LEAD TO SAVINGS
AND AGAIN I'M WILLING TO SET A
PRETTY HIGH BAR FOR THAT.
EVIDENCE RIGHT BUT WHEN THEY
DOES WHAT IT DOES WE SHOULD
REFLECT THAT IN THE OUT YEARS
THE SAVINGS AND SO CAN YOU SPEAK.
TO CREATING THAT KIND OF
CAPACITY WITHIN THE LA L. TO BE
ABLE TO DO THAT.
WELL THE SENATOR PAN YES THIS IS --
ACTUALLY AN AREA THAT I THINK
WOULD.
FALL WITHIN. ONE OF THE FOR
POINTS THAT I BROUGHT UP AT THE
END OF MY PRESENTATION AS ONE OF
THE PRIORITIES THAT I HAVE WHICH
IS.
TO BUILD OUT THIS LONG RUN
OUTLOOK TO EXAMINE FUTURE FUTURE
BUDGET PRESSURES EMERGING ISSUES.
MY VIEW IS THAT THAT TYPE OF IF
COULD BE BUILT INTO SOMETHING
THAT LOOKS AT TRENDS OVER THE
LONGER TERM.
AND YOU COULD ENVISIONED WE HAD
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THIS JUST LAST
WEEK INTERNALLY YOU CAN ENVISION.
POTENTIALLY DOING SOME KIND OF
SCENARIO ANALYSIS OF IF WE DON'T
MAKE THIS INTERVENTION IF WE DO
MAKE THIS INTERVENTION.
AND I I DO THINK THERE'S
POTENTIAL TO DO THAT AND YOU
KNOW.
ANYBODY THAT HAS EVER YOU KNOW
HAD A HOME.
YOU KNOW THAT SOMETIMES.
MONEY YOU SPEND TODAY MAY SEEM
LIKE A LOT BUT IT'S GOING TO
COST A LOT MORE IF YOU WAIT TEN
YEARS TO DEAL WITH WHATEVER
LEAKY ROOF FOR PROBLEM THE HAVE
SO.
I MEAN I I DEFINITELY TAKE YOUR
POINT AND I THINK IT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE WILL --
BE THINKING ABOUT OKAY --
I I CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THAT
BECAUSE I THINK THAT --
TOO OFTEN WHEN WE LOOK AT ISSUES
WE SIMPLY SAY WELL THIS IS THE
UP FRONT COSTS AND WE NEED TO
STAFF ON THE ON GOING BASIS IS
THERE NOT.
BUT THERE'S A REASON WHY WE'RE
INVESTING IN THAT AND AND
FRANKLY YOU KNOW FOR EXAMPLE
EVEN ON THE I. T. PROJECTS I'VE
CHALLENGE PEOPLE SAID OKAY FINE
WE'RE MAKING THIS INVESTMENT IT
OF BAY L. CREW CALL THE SERVICE
AT CENTER AND THIS IS NOT JUST
ABOUT IT BY THE WAY.
BUT LIKE IS IT GOING TO MAKE US
MORE FISH THESE TASKS THAT IS SO
SO I THINK THERE'S A WIDE
VARIETY OF RANGE OF THINGS --
I THINK A LOT HUMAN SERVICES AND
HEALTH CARE STUFF AS WELL --
WESHOULD BE LOOKING AT THAT
BECAUSE I WE SAID THAT ONE AWAY
AS WE PREPARE FOR A FUTURE
DOWNTURN IS ONE WAY IS OF COURSE
WE PUT SOME MONEY ASIDE FOR THAT
BUT THE OTHER THING IS IS THAT
WE MAKE THE INVESTMENTS WHILE WE
HAVE THE FUNDS.
THAT LEAD TO THE KIND OF CHANGES
IN THE WAY WE DO THINGS.
THAT THEN MAKE US MORE RESILIENT
THAT ALSO SEE THIS MY IN THE
FUTURE IN FACT I'D ARGUE THAT
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT WERE
PAYING FOR NOW AS A RESULT OF
DECISIONS SHORT TERM DECISIONS
ARE MADE.
DURING PREVIOUS DOWNTURNS THAT
WE'RE NOT PAYING THE PRICE FOR
NOW.
AS WELL AND SO --
ANDSO WE ARE SPENDING MORE NOW
THAT WE COULD IT COULD HAVE
BECAUSE PEOPLE MADE REALLY SHORT
TERM DECISIONS BACK THEN.
THEY HAD A YOUNG DEFICIT THE
DEAL AT SITE AND ARE STAND THE
CHALLENGE AT THAT TIME.
BUT WE SHOULD BE LOOKING AT
THESE THINGS THAT WE CAN MAKE
THEBEST POSSIBLE DECISIONS I
APPRECIATE YOU.
YOUR DESIRE TO BUILD THAT
CAPACITY IN THE L. L. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR PAN
BEFORE I MOVE OVER TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TEAM WHO WILL BE FOLLOWED
BY SENATOR SKINNER WE GOT THE
DATA THIS IS JUST FASCINATING
OUR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
THEY HAVE A STATE AUDITS UNIT SO
THEY HAVE MULTIPLE FUNCTIONS.
MUCH LIKE THE LA L. BEYOND JUST
THE BUDGET BUT THEY HAVE TEN
TIMES THE NUMBER OF EMPLOYEES
AND LA L..
IN THE CURRENT BUDGET THERE ARE
FOUR HUNDRED AND FORTY EIGHT
STAFF WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
I'M NOT THROWING SHADE FINANCE.
I'M JUST SAYING IT GIVES US A
CONTACT US ALL IN TERMS OF
MAKING SURE WE SUPPORT THIS BILL
MAKING SURE WE GET THE RESOURCES
TO THE TABLE TO MAKE SURE THAT
OUR ENTITY.
IS A PROPERLY RESOURCE TO DO THE
JOB THAT WE EXPECTED THEM AND
THAT THEY ARE THAT THE STATUTE
REQUIRES OF THEM. TEN TIMES THE
NUMBER OF EMPLOYEES MR TING.
THE FAQ MARRIAGE I THINK IT'S AN
EXCELLENT POINT ESPECIALLY WHEN
WE REVIEW THAT THE IMPETUS. FOR
THE CREATION OF THIS OFFICE WAS
TO PROVIDE THE ACCOUNT AWAY
COUNTER BALANCE TO THE PART OF
JOB OF THAT AT THIS POINT --
SO JUST JUST A COUPLE QUESTIONS
CAN CAN YOU DESCRIBE TO ME THAT
PROCESS --
THAT MEMBERS AND STAFF REQUEST
INFORMATION BECAUSE THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT HAS NEVER BEEN
COMPLETELY CLEAR TO ME OR I
DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S A FORMAL.
FORMAL PROCESS WAS A TO SORT OF
INFORMAL DOESN'T LIKE PEOPLE
PASS NOTES IN THE HALL IS IT --
JUST SORT OF SHE TOLD PEOPLE
SEND INFORMATION BY CARRIER
PIGEON I DON'T KNOW.
HOW THAT?
HOW HOW THE I THE THE ONLY
REASON I BASS I'VE NEVER BEEN
ABLE TO GET ANY OF MY REQUEST?
NO IMPLEMENTED SO SO I HAVE
COMPLETE INTEREST IN REALLY.
BUT I'VE HAD MY REQUEST MET YEAH
CLEARLY THAT I I'LL CALL ALL MY
METHODS HAVE BEEN.
COULD YOU USE.
I I'M I'M GONNA USE AL BY THE
FUTURE -- SO.
I'M.
SORRY TO HEAR THAT WE WE WILL
AND FROM WHAT FROM WHAT I SEE
THIS IS A PRIORITY AREA WAS IN
THE OFFICE AND THE WAY THAT WE
SEE THAT I'VE SEEN THAT WE
RECEIVE THESE REQUESTS.
DOES VARY WIDELY SO SOME OF THEM
ARE MALES ARE PHONE CALLS
SUBMITTING A QUESTION.
THERE ARE TIMES WHEN A QUESTION
WILL COME IN.
WELL LET ME JUST SAY THAN THE
OTHER ONES ARE THE MORE FORMAL
ONES THAT ARE ASKING US TO KIND
OF THE VALUE WAIT SOME POTENTIAL
CHANGE.
THERE HAVE BEEN TIMES WHERE I
THINK WE RECEIVE QUESTIONS THAT
REQUIRE FOLLOW UP ON OUR PART
BECAUSE THE DATA MIGHT NOT BE
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER.
THE QUESTION IN THE WAY THAT IT
WAS ASKED AND SO WE TRY TO
FOLLOW UP WITH SORT OF LIKE A
SCOPING MEETING WHERE WE
DISCUSSED WITH WHOEVER REQUESTED
IT TO TRY TO SCOPE IT DOWN TO
SOMETHING WE CAN.
WE CAN DO BUT IS ALSO STILL
USEFUL TO THE REQUESTER.
THE OTHER THERE IS THE
MANAGEMENT SIDE OF THIS BECAUSE
WHILE WE TRACK THESE MEMBER
REQUESTS AND YOU CAN SEE THEM ON
ON THE TABLE HERE THERE'S YOU
KNOW OVER A HUNDRED OF THEM.
THESE ARE ONLY THE ONES THAT.
TOOK YOU KNOW TWO OR THREE DAYS
OR MORE FOR US TO WORK ON THERE
ARE MANY MANY THAT WE RECEIVE
THAT ARE RESPONDED TO WITHIN A
COUPLE OF HOURS.
OR SHORTER TIME FRAME.
AND SO WHILE I'M NOT SAYING THAT
TO PAT OURSELVES ON THE BACK AND
SAYING THAT BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW
THAT WE'RE DOING A SUFFICIENTLY
GOOD JOB JUST TRACKING THE
QUESTIONS THAT COME IN AND WHAT
HAPPENS TO THEM.
HOW WE RESPOND AND SO I KNOW IN
SOME SENSE IT ALMOST CREATES
MORE WORK GREAT FOR THE STAFF
LIKE NOT ONLY DO I HAVE TO
ANSWER THE QUESTION AFTER
DOCUMENT ANSWERING THE QUESTION
AND SO?
I'M THINKING ABOUT WAYS KIND OF
EVALUATING OR WORK PROCESS WITH
OUR WITH OUR STAFF AND
MANAGEMENT --
WAYS.
TO STREAMLINE THE PROCESS TO
RECORD THE QUESTIONS THAT COME
IN IN FACT.
MR SYDNEY ONE OF THE FORMER
DEPUTY TO MY ATTENTION A VERY
GOOD IDEA OF EVEN DEVELOPING AN
APP WHERE YOUR TECHNOLOGY
ORIENTED STAFF MEMBERS COULD GO
ON AND AND SUBMIT A REQUEST AND
HOPEFULLY THEN IT WOULD BE
RECORDED.
AND AND FUNNELED TO THE YOU KNOW
THE PROPER SECTION SO.
IT'S A LITTLE BIT OF A WORK IN
PROGRESS I THINK BUT YOU KNOW
THAT THAT IS MY UNDERSTANDING OF
HOW WE DO IT THIS TIME.
SO I THINK  WOULD REALLY
ENCOURAGE YOU.
TO DEVELOP A FORMALIZED PROCESS
I THINK --
QUITE OFTEN --
THINGS ARE DONE INFORMALLY IN
THIS BUILDING.
AND I THINK IT'S TO OUR TO OUR
DETRIMENT SO IT REALLY NEEDS TO
BE IN MY OPINION KIND OF
PROFESSIONAL EYES --
I KNOW THAT THIS IS MY MY SEVEN
I'M SORRY MY SEVENTY YEAR HERE
THE FACT THAT I DON'T KNOW --
OW THAT PROCESS WORKS OR --
HOW HOW TO GO DO IT I THINK SAYS
SOMETHING AND?
WHAT I ALSO DIDN'T KNOW THAT YOU
REPORTER YOUR PC SO THAT SAYS
SOMETHING --
SO I THINK THAT THEY WOULD JUST
BE REALLY BEHOOVE ALL OF US
ESPECIALLY AS NEW MEMBER
ACTUALLY IN A WAY TOO MUCH TURN
IN THIS LEGISLATURE REALLY --
LOOK FOR TO LITTLE MORE
STABILITY IN THAT BUT I THINK
THAT WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL.
SO -- JUST
JUST ANOTHER ON SORT OF JUST
KATAKANA COMMENTING YOU CAN FEEL
FREE.
TO THE COULD TO DISCUSS THE TWO
IS. ONE OF THE THINGS --
I I REALLY DID APPRECIATE
SITTING --
IN BUDGET SUB TO WHEN I WAS A
MEMBER THERE IS JUST THE
ANALYSIS AND THE INFORMATION
THAT WAS REALLY REALLY DEVELOPED --
ONE QUESTION THAT I DID ALWAYS
HAVE WAS THERE'S ALWAYS SOME
SORT OF RECOMMENDATION.
SOME KIND OF AT THE END AND I
THINK ON RATHER THAN.
YOU KNOW NOT JUST KIND OF POSE A
SENSE AT THE SORT OF FOOD FOR
THOUGHT AS RAT RATHER THAN
HAVING A SORT OF FINAL
RECOMMENDATION PERCENT THINK
WHAT WOULD OFTEN BE HELPFUL.
WOULD BE IT'S SORT OF A LIST OF
OPTIONS ARE ABOUT IT SO I KIND
OF WOULD GET I WOULD READ THE
ANALYSIS TO GET TO THE
CONCLUSION I BE LIKE WELL HOW DO
THEY HOW THEY GET HERE.
HOW DID THEY GET TO THE END?
AND RIGHT RATHER THAN SAY HEY
THIS IS THE ONE AND ONLY
RECOMMENDATION OR ANSWER --
IT'LL BE PROBABLY MORE HELPFUL
TO HAVE A VARIETY OF OPTIONS
THAT WE ARE REALLY.
LOOKING AT AS POLICY OPTIONS TO
HELP US IN FRAMING ARE THINKING
I THINK ANOTHER PART WITHIN THE
BUDGET.
RESPONSE BECAUSE I KNOW THAT THE
STAFF ARE ARE THERE AT ALL THE
HEROES I SING THE SAME SAME IN
THE SENATE --
I THINK IT PROBABLY WOULD.
BE.
GOOD FOR THE STAFF TO ALSO I
THINK INTERFACE MORE FOR THAT
WITH THE MEMBERS I KNOW THAT THE
LA -- STACK
INTERVIEW INNER --
SORT OF CONTACTS MY BUDGET.
COMMITTEE STAFF QUITE OFTEN
THERE DURING COSTS DIALOGUE BUT
I THINK THERE THERE'S A THERE'S
A MISSING.
ON LINK IS REALLY TALKING TO THE
MEMBERSHIP TALKING TO THE
MEMBERS THE SUB CHAIRS THINGS
LIKE THAT I DON'T THINK.
THOSE DISCUSSIONS HAPPENED AND
ANY SORT OF REGULARITIES I THINK
THAT WOULD BE --
SORT OF MUCH MORE HELPFUL TO YOU
KNOW WHAT ARE THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THINKING WELL YOU KNOW
WHAT'S DRIVING SOME THAT'S I
THINK OUT.
SO THAT WHEN THE OPTIONS COME
OUT THERE A LITTLE MORE --
IN SYNC WITH WHAT THE DIALOGUE
AS WELL THANK YOU IF THE LOSER
FOR VERY FAIR POINTS A HOPE THAT
YOU HEARD IN SOME OF MY COMMENTS
TO THAT IS A PRIORITY FOR ME.
AND I DO I KNOW --
THE SOMETIMES.
THE REPORTS THAT WE PRODUCE --
THAT MIGHT BE THIS MIGHT BE ONE
AREA WHERE IT'S THE LOOK AND
FEEL COMPONENT OF THE REPORT
THAT I MENTIONED.
COULD COULD HELP IN THIS WAY
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT SOMETIMES
THE DO DEVELOP A MENU OF
ALTERNATIVE CAN OPTIONS FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER AND
INCORPORATING.
STRENGTHS AND WEAKNESSES BUT IT
MAY NOT ALWAYS.
BE EASILY IDENTIFIED A QUICK A
QUICK WAY AND I THINK THERE
COULD BE OPPORTUNITIES FOR US TO
SORT OF PRESENT THE INFORMATION
IN A MANNER THAT STE --
WHAT I I'VE BEEN CALLING THEM
ALMOST LIKE TERROR SHE YOU KNOW
WE HAVE THIS LONG REPORT FOR
THAT IS THERE FOR BACK UP YOUR
STAFF FOR YOU WHEN YOU HAVE?
TIME AND IT'S ON YOUR DESK YOU
CAN LOOK AT IT LATER IN THE DAY
OR SOMETHING BUT YOU MIGHT NEED
JUST TO KNOW WHAT'S THE BOTTOM
LINE WHAT IS LA --
THINKING ABOUT THIS AND IN THAT
WAY MAYBE IT COULD HELP IN THAT
REGARD OF I THINK UP ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING JUST THAT THE THE FINAL
POINT IS.
ON THE ASSIGNMENT OF WAR
REGARDING THE REPORTS THAT ARE
GIVEN TO MEMBERS REQUESTS ARE
PART OF THE BUDGET.
I THINK IT WOULD BE HELPFUL TO
HAVE THAT IN SOME SOME LEVEL OF
DISCUSSION OR CONSULTATION WITH
JAIL BC --
BECAUSE EVERY YEAR OR I I KNOW
IN THE FALL WE'RE GOING TO HEAR
YOU KNOW WE CAN KIND OF PROTECT
HERE ARE.
A HERO HERE WE JUST SEE COMING
YEAH FIVE ISSUES.
THAT ARE HOT LIKE IMAGES JUST
FOR EXAMPLE NOT REALLY IN THE
PURVIEW OF LA --
BUT SOMETHING THAT WE'RE ALL
JUST REALLY TRYING TO GRAPPLE
WITH THE IS ON TOP OF THE
WILDFIRES IS REALLY WHAT'S GOING
TO HAPPEN.
REGARDING ALL THE I'LL.
I KNOW THAT THERE ARE UTILITIES
COMMITTEES ARE REALLY GRAPPLING
WITH THAT BUT FROM A BROADER.
POINT OF VIEW THAT IT IT'S NOT
ENOUGH FOR EVEN THE COMMITTEES
TO WAIT FOR A BILL.
IT DID THIS IS RELEASING THAT
THAT'S MUCH BIGGER THINKING
ABOUT HOW ENERGY IS GOING TO BE
PROVIDED HOW TO PROVIDE IT
SAFELY.
ON HOW IT'S DONE IN LINK TO JUST
THAT NOT NOT JUST HIS EYES AS AN
EXAMPLE THAT'S JUST AN EXAMPLE
OF THEM THAT WE ARE.
SORT OF RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE OF
AND YOU KNOW REALLY THERE'S A
DOES AVOID AND THINKING AND
RESEARCH AND TO A POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS BUT THAT'S JUST
ONE OF I WOULD SAY --
THEREFORE FIVE THINGS I THINK
UNIVERSAL HEALTHCARE SINGLE
PAYER ISSUES HAVE BEEN SORT OF
DOMINANT OF LAST COUPLE DECADES
BUT THAT'S AND THAT'S REALLY
BEEN.
PART OF THE POLICY DISCUSSION OF
LAST COUPLE YEARS AND HAS ALSO.
LACKED A HEY WE HEAR SOME PURE
SOME REALLY --
ACADEMIC OFF BEHIND IT WHICH I
THINK THE OFFICE COULD BE
EXTREMELY EXTREMELY HELPFUL WITH.
SO ON THE THOSE ARE JUST A
COUPLE A COUPLE THOUGHTS TO JUST
SAY HEY I THINK WE WE REALLY
VALUE THE OFFICE WE REALLY WOULD
LOVE TO HELP WITH OFFICE BY
THINK THERE NEEDS TO BE.
A LITTLE MORE OF SYNC BETWEEN
BETWEEN US IN THE OFFICE.
UNDERSTOOD THANK YOU.
REMIND ME WHAT TIME OF YEAR --
BUT I KNOW I CAN'T BE THE MIDDLE
THE BUDGET ANALYSIS THAT THE
OFFICE TYPICALLY DOES THESE KIND
OF FORWARD THINKING.
DOCUMENTS THEY TEND TO BE
RELEASED --
MORE IN THE POST BUDGET PERIOD
MMHM YOU KNOW MAYBE JULY THROUGH --
OCTOBER BECAUSE THEN YOU GET TO
NOVEMBER AND THAT'S WHEN THE
FORECAST IS COMING OUT RIGHT
THERE'S ACTUALLY A SMALL WINDOW.
ALTHOUGH.
OF COURSE THAT GOES INTO THOSE
REPORTS HAS STARTED WELL BEFORE
THAT SOMETIMES IT EVEN TAKES
MORE THAN A YEAR.
SO THAT'S THE PHASE WHERE I I
THINK THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
US TO HAVE DISCUSSIONS WITH JAIL
BC MEMBERS AND AND OTHERS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S SOME.
YOU KNOW THAT YOU'RE NOT EVER
SURPRISED OR CUT OFF FLAT FOOTED
BY WHAT WE PRODUCE AND SO I
ASKED THAT JUST BECAUSE OF THAT
I THINK WE SHOULD COMMIT COMMIT
AS JAIL B. C. THAN TO CONVENE
ANOTHER HEARING TO GO DEEPER
INTO THAT CONVERSATION BECAUSE
IF YOU.
POLL EVERY MEMBER THE D. L. B.
C. YOU WILL GET A VERY DIFFERENT
LIST I'M SURE SO IF WE COULD
CONVENE AS A G. L. B. C. TO HAVE
THAT SPECIFIC CONVERSATION.
I THINK THAT'S ONLY FAIR TO YOU
AND HELPFUL TO US WE SHOULD
FOLLOW UP ON THAT --
WITH REGARD TO THE REQUESTS I
THINK THAT IS A GREAT IDEA TO
FORMALIZE THE PROCESS.
IN THE MEAN TIME --
HOW DO YOU COMMUNICATE TO OUR
STAFF BECAUSE THE REQUEST COME
FROM THE STAFF AND MAKING SURE
THAT STAFF?
KNOW WHO TO DIRECT THE REQUEST
TO IS IT A SINGLE POINT OF ENTRY
INTO THE ALEJO OR DO THEY SEND
THE EMAIL TO THE ANALYSTS THEY
KNOW WHO DOES THE WORK IN THAT
AREA.
I THINK IT'S APPROPRIATE THAT AS
YOU DO YOUR VISITS WITH MEMBERS
THAT PERHAPS YOU BRING A
DIRECTOR OR SOMETHING SO THE
MEMBER.
UNDERSTANDS WHO TO ASK WHAT OF
AND THE MEMBER STAFF ARE CLEAR
ABOUT WHO TO DIRECT QUESTIONS TO
IT MIGHT BE.
KIND OF THAT FOUNDATIONAL AND
LASTLY I WOULD SAY AGAIN.
RECOGNIZE THAT WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO TAKE IN TERMS
OF THIS RELATIONSHIP.
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE THERE'S
NOTHING CURRENTLY THAT WOULD
PRECLUDE A BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
CHAIR FROM REACHING OUT IN
ASKING DIRECTLY FOR A BRIEFING
FROM THE ANALYSTS WHO WORKS IN A
PARTICULAR AREA.
SOLD OUT COMMUNICATE THAT TO MY
SUBCOMMITTEE CHAIRS I HOPE YOU
DO THE SAME AND SO WE CAN KICK
START THAT PROCESS BY THE
SUBCOMMITTEE CHAIRS --
RECOGNIZE THAT THE LA --
IS A RESOURCE THAT CAN EITHER BE
A PART OF YOUR BRIEF INTERVIEW
CHOOSE TO DO THAT WE CAN
INITIATE THAT BY EXTENDING THE
INVITATION. TO THEM AND I KNOW
THAT YOU KNOW I I BROADER
MEMBERSHIP OF THE LEGISLATURE'S
AWARE THAT WE DO THAT BECAUSE I
KNOW OUR STAFF ON CERTAIN TOPICS
THEY DO DO THAT I THINK THE
ISSUE THAT I THAT WERE
IDENTIFIED IS THAT. TO SOME
EXTENT.
IT'S IT'S BEEN DONE ON AN AD HOC
BASIS.
YOU KNOW SOME OF THE STAFF KNOW
THE TO THE PARTICULAR ANALYST IN
OUR OFFICE IS RIGHT YOU KNOW
THAT'S GREAT BUT I WOULD LIKE IT
TO BE MORE --
WELL ESTABLISHED THREE WORDS
AGREED I WAS TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT AS YOU FIGURE OUT YOUR STE
INFRASTRUCTURE JUST ON AN
INTERIM BASIS JUST TO MAKE SURE
THAT.
ALL THE MEMBERS HERE AND THE
STAFF WITHIN THE SOUND OF OUR
VOICES HERE TODAY UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE IS A PROCESS THAT WE
COULD USE AN INTERIM --
WAY ON TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
GETTING THEIR MEMBER REQUEST TO
THE RIGHT PERSON [inaudible]
SERVICE SKINNER.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
AND ONE ECHO SOME OF THE
COMMENTS THAT --
BOTH THE CHAIR MADE AND ARE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET YEAR --
AND WILL WELCOME MISTER TECH.
DID I GET THAT ONE RIGHT DID I
DO THAT CORRECTLY.
OKAY THE TECH OKAY SO SEE I GOT
LOCKED INTO AND I WASN'T EVEN.
HEADACHE THAT'S OKAY I WILL.
WRITE THAT DOWN PHONETICALLY AND
NOT PUT IT ON AGAIN --
ANYWAY -- I
I HAD A BIT OF A REPUTATION
BECAUSE WHEN I WAS THE CHAIR OF
THE CONFERENCE COMMITTEE A
NUMBER OF YEARS AGO.
I DID NOT CALL ON THE LA --
AS FREQUENTLY AS PREVIOUS
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE CHAIRS HAD.
AND I WANT TO DO IS CONVEY SOME
OF THE THINGS THAT WERE ALREADY
EXPRESSED --
REFLECT WHY I DID NOT DO SO.
I VERY MUCH VALUE THE ANALYSIS
THAT THE LA --
PROVIDES US BUT WHAT I IN THOSE
CONTEXTS WHAT I WANT.
IS ANALYSIS NOW THAT ISN'T THAT
DOES NOT MEAN THAT.
THE OPINION OF PEOPLE THAT HAVE.
ANALYZED THOSE THINGS THAT ARE
NOT LEGITIMATE FOR US TO
CONSIDER.
BUT WHEN THIS WHEN THE ISSUE
BEFORE US HASN'T REALLY BEEN
ANALYZED.
THEN MY ISSUE WAS I'M NOT BEING
PROVIDED NECESSARILY IMPARTIAL
DATA OR SOMETHING TO WAY I'M
BEING GIVEN --
AN OPINION AND AGAIN THAT SOME
PEOPLE MAY SAY WELL LA --
SHOULD BE ABLE TO EXPRESS AN
OPINION BUT I WANT THAT BACKED
BY.
THAT ANALYSIS AND THERE WERE IT
WAS MY EXPERIENCE IN THAT YEAR
AND THE YEAR BEFORE THAT THERE
WAS.
A NUMBER OF SUBJECT AREAS WHERE.
ELLIE --
STAFF WOULD OPINE AND I WOULD
ASK IS THAT BASED ON EIGHT YOU
KNOW SOME RESEARCH THAT WAS DONE
OR SOME DATA THAT YOU HAVE FOR
US OR I WOULD ASK VARIOUS
QUESTIONS LIKE THAT.
AND IT WOULD NOT BE.
AND SO THAT WAS FRUSTRATING FOR
ME BECAUSE IT WAS I WOULD I FELT
I WAS GETTING LESS.
OF THE OF WHAT THE ROLE OF THE
LA -- REALLY.
IS FOR US.
NOW OF COURSE WEIGHING THE
NUMBER ALL HAS COMPARED TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I MEAN SHE
SO CLEARLY I APPRECIATE.
THAT OUR SUBCOMMITTEE HAS.
LOOKED AT THAT IN HIGHLIGHTED IT
AS SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO
LOOK AT BECAUSE I THINK ALL OF
US AND I WILL SPEAK NOW FOR
MYSELF.
I REALLY VALUE THAT ANALYSIS AND
WE NEED IT --
NOW LET ME JUST.
SAY SOME OTHER THINGS SO WE WE
GET REPORTS FROM THEIR LEO.
WE ALSO GET REPORTS FROM THE
LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION.
STATE AUDITOR.
SOMETIMES IN THE SAME YEAR OR
TWO YEAR PERIOD.
THERE IS AN OVERLAP BETWEEN NOT
I MEAN OBVIOUSLY LET'S GIVE AN
EXAMPLE THE STATE AUDITOR JUST
AUDITED CALIFORNIA'S.
REHABILITATION PROGRAMS IN OUR
PRISON SYSTEM.
THE LA --
DID A REPORT ON OUR
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS I
BELIEVE IT WAS.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN I DON'T THINK
THE LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION IS
AWAITING YET.
BUT CLEARLY CALIFORNIA BOTH I'M
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTION BUDGETARY
DIRECTION AND THE VOTERS.
HAS IS MADE IT A PRIORITY THAT
WE WANT TO THAT NOT ONLY WE WANT
TO PROVIDE QUALITY RE UP BUT WE
HAVE --
DESIGNED THE WHOLE SYSTEM IN THE
ABILITY FOR A PERSON TO GET
BEFORE PRO BOARD BASED ON IT SO
CLEARLY IT IS IN AN AREA THAT'S
VERY VERY IMPORTANT TO US --
BUT WHAT WOULD I THINK BE
HELPFUL IS WHEN.
WHEN A DIFFERENT ENTITIES LIKE
THE L. LIKE THE AUDITOR DOES
SUCH REPORT?
IF THE LA --
GIVEN THEIR EXPERTISE.
CAN.
TAKE THAT INFORMATION AND
CORPORATE IT WITH WHAT LA --
KNOWS IN THE ANALYSIS LA ALWAYS
DONE SO THAT WE HAVE.
A BETTER PICTURE AS WE PROCEED
WITH HOW WE WANT AS WE FIGURE
OUT HOW WE WANT TO PROCEED SO
IT'S NOT JUST KIND OF LIKE ANY
MEANING MIND YOU MùT WHICH YOU
KNOW WHICH OF THESE.
ARE WE WHATEVER DO WE EITHER
THINK IS VALID OR AND I THOUGHT
THAT IF WE TAKE THE THERE WAS
SOME VERY GOOD INFORMATION IN
THERE BUT ALSO FELT IT DID NOT.
INCOME IS THE BIG PICTURE.
OF WHAT IT WAS LEGITIMATELY
LOOKING AT CERTAIN --
THE SYSTEMATIC PROBLEMS IN IN
CDC ARE OF NOT PROPERLY TRACKING
WHO IS IN THE PROGRAM'S.
NOT --
PROVIDING THEM EQUALLY ACROSS
YARDS AND NOT A NECESSARILY --
SKY SCHEDULING OUR LISTING THE
INMATE'S APPROPRIATELY GIVEN OUR
OTHER POLICIES.
BUT IT THERE WERE SOME BIGGER
PICTURE THINGS THAT WERE REALLY
MISSING AND THINGS THAT THE LA --
HAS STUDIED IN OPINED ON SO
HAVING THE LA --
COME BACK TO US BEFORE E JUST
ACT ON THE AUDITOR'S REPORT
WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL NOW I WANT
TO LIE DETAIL THERE BUT I CAN.
I CAN GIVE LOTS MORE EXAMPLES
THE DMV IS ANOTHER ONE DMV IS
GUNS I MEAN THE LA ALWAYS DONE
VERY BRIEF JUST LIKE HAND OUT ON
OUR DMV ISSUES THE AUDITOR NOW
IS DONE A WHOLE LOT IT.
WE'VE GOT THE GOVERNOR'S TO TO
PUT MONEY AND YOU KNOW BUT IT'S
LIKE KATE CAN WE TAKE THE
VARIOUS EXPERTISE WE HAVE.
AND RY TO SYNCHRONIZE IT SOME
SO THAT WE ARE BEING GIVEN.
THAT OPTIMAL RECOMMENDATIONS AND
AGAIN KNOWING WITH ONE S. WE
DON'T ALWAYS RESPOND BUT AT
LEAST WOULD BE HELPFUL --
THEN -- ALL
AT THE ELLIE OWES SUBJECT MATTER
REPORTS SAY IN THE LAST THREE
YEARS THEY LEGITIMATELY COVERED
THINGS THAT.
ARE YOU KNOW ON ARM THAT HAVE
BEEN VERY PRESSING OR THAT ARE
CONSISTENTLY THINGS THAT WE
SHOULD FOLLOW PAY ATTENTION TO
BUDGETARY LEE.
SO THEY'VE BEEN IN THE AREA OF
FIRE RECOVERY FIRE RESPONSE
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS DISASTER.
OBVIOUSLY LEGITIMATE GIVEN THE
LAST FEW YEARS WHETHER IT'S
FLOODS FIRES YOU NAME IT.
ALSO MEDI CAL AND OTHER HEALTH
PROGRAMS CHILD CARE BECAUSE
THAT'S BEEN SOMETHING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS BEEN INCREASING
FUNDING FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS
AND IS AND THE GOVERNOR NOW HE'S
ALSO GOT A GREAT.
INTEREST IN ADVANCING SO THERE'S
MANY MANY REPORT YOU'VE DONE IN
THAT SUBJECT AREA IN HOUSING.
BUT THEN WHEN I THINK ABOUT.
SO THOSE ARE ALL.
LEGITIMATE AND FOLLOW THINGS
THAT WE ARE EITHER ENGAGED IN
GREATLY OR SHOULD BE BUT THEN
WHEN I STEP BACK AND I THINK
ABOUT SOME OF THE OTHER THINGS
THAT POTENTIALLY.
WE SHOULD BE ENGAGED IN THAT
HAVEN'T BEEN WAITIN AND THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET YOUR MENTION THE
I. O. U.'S.
A COUPLE OF OTHERS --
BUT OUR CALIFORNIA WAS ONE OF
THE FIRST STATE TO BELIEVE WE
WERE THE FIRST TO SET INCREDIBLY
AMBITIOUS WASTE REDUCTION GOALS.
AND RECYCLING GOALS.
AND WE DON'T A PRETTY GOOD JOB
OF IT.
BUT WE HAVE NOT WE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS HAVE NOT REALLY
LOOKED CLOSELY AS TO WHETHER
WERE IN FACT REDUCING WASTE NOW.
AND THERE'S BEEN A TOTAL CRISIS
WE DEPEND ON WE CALIFORNIA ON
SENDING THE MATERIALS SOMEWHERE
ELSE.
JOINT INDONESIA WHEREVER AND
HOPING THAT THEY'LL DO SOMETHING
WITH THEM THOSE MARKETS HAVE
MORE LESS COLLAPSED.
SO WHAT WHICH NOW IT IT'S NOT
CLEAR TO ME THAT WE REALLY HAVE
WASTE REDUCTION MUCH AT ALL.
AND THAT'S GONNA BE LOOMING
GREATER AND GREATER PROBLEM AND
YET OUR FOR OUR WHOLE FOUNDATION
OF OUR POLICIES ARE ASTE
POLICIES ARE CLIMATE PROTECTION
PAUL ARE ALL BASED ON THAT WHICH
IS COULD BE BRIGHT NOW MYTHICAL.
SO.
IT YOU KNOW SOME LOOK AT THAT
FROM A BIG PICTURE I THINK WOULD
BE VERY HELPFUL THE OTHER THING
IS.
REVENUE SOURCES THE LA --
AS TOO MANY OTHERS ABOUT THE
VOLATILITY OF CALIFORNIA'S
DEPENDENCE ON PERSONAL INCOME
TAX.
BUT IT WHAT I'VE SEEN LESS OF IS.
THAT BIG PICTURE WHAT ARE THE
REVENUE SOURCES THAT HAVE
DROPPED WHAT ARE THE REVENUE
SOURCES THAT HAVE HISTORICALLY
BEEN STABLE BUT THAT WE PRETEND
TO WE ARE NOT --
IF --
PROPERLY ADVANTAGES.
SO WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH SALES
TAX NOW THAT WE HAVE FAR LESS
BRICK AND MORTAR.
OPERATE TAX FOR EXAMPLE IS I'VE
STARTED TO LOOK AT SOME RESEARCH
AND IT IS THAT AS A PORTION OF
OUR GENERAL FUND.
OTHER THAN ONE LITTLE BLIP
YOU'RE IN THE RECESSION IT IS
THE LOWEST PORTION OF OUR
GENERAL FUND IT IS EVER BEEN IN
HISTORY.
AND YET CORPORATIONS NOW ARE
WEALTHIER THAN THEY HAVE EVER
BEEN.
AND RECEIVED THE BIGGEST TAX
WINDFALL FROM THE FEDS.
AND YOUR CALIFORNIA'S OF A
COLLECTING VERY LITTLE.
AND IS THAT A SUSTAINABLE OR
STABLE WAY FOR US TO HAVE OUR
TAX STRUCTURE.
AND THEN FINALLY ANOTHER ONE
THAT -- AND
I KNOW THAT THIS SESSION IS NOT
REALLY FOR US TO DO WITH OUR
PERSONAL BUT I'M TRYING.
TO THINK ABOUT THOSE OVERVIEW IS.
GREAT IS THOSE.
AREAS OF OUR BUDGET.
THAT HAVE GROWN CLEARLY
EDUCATION LEGITIMATE LEAD THE
DEMAND THE NEGROES.
BUT THOSE AREAS WHERE WE SHOULD
BE PAYING ATTENTION.
THAT THE STATE DID THEIR GROWING
ONE PERHAPS ONE COULD CALL STATE
ALL SAY DISPROPORTIONATELY
SOMEBODY ELSE MAYBE SHOULDN'T
PUT ST THE SAME.
VALUE JUDGMENT ON IT BUT RATHER.
WHAT IS SO LET'S ALL GIVE THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE ONE FOR EXAMPLE
WE HAVE --
POPULATION DOWN WE HAVE DONE
REAL WHAT WE'VE DONE ALL THESE
THINGS.
AND YET.
ARE NOT YET WE KNOW SOME OF THE
REASONS WHY.
BUT IF IF.
THE NUMBERS WERE TO CONTINUE TO
GROW AS THEY HAVE SAY IN THE
LAST FIVE YEARS.
WHAT WE COULD GET TO A SITUATION
WHERE CORRECTIONS WAS? 30% OF
OUR GF MAYBE THAT'S AN
EXAGGERATION BUT IN IS THAT
REALLY THE DIRECTION WE WANT TO
GO IN.
AND SO I BRING IT UP BECAUSE
VERY OFTEN. FOR MYSELF AS CHAIR
OF THAT SUBCOMMITTEE THE
ANALYSIS OF EACH LITTLE
INDEPENDENT BUDGET REQUEST WHICH
IS A TEENY THING.
VERSUS ANY KIND OF ANALYSIS OVER
THIS BIG PICTURE WHAT SHOULD WE
BE DOING SO THAT WE CAN OVER
TIME.
YOU KNOW GET GET THESE THINGS
UNDER CONTROL SO THOSE ARE THE
ISSUES THAT ARE ON MY MIND AND I
APPRECIATE BEING ABLE TO EXPRESS
AND THANK YOU.
YOU THANK YOU MISTER OBERNOLTE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. TWO
THINGS ARE ONE OF THE NEW
BRIEFLY HERE ONE IS TO AMPLIFY
SOMETHING THAT YOU JUST HEARD
FROM SOMEONE TING AND FROM-SENATOR SKINNER.
ABOUT THE A WILDFIRE LIABILITY
ISSUE AND I THINK THAT THAT WAS
REALLY MISSED OPPORTUNITY BY THE
LA -- LAST
YEAR NOT TO WEIGH IN ON THAT AND
YOU KNOW NOT AT A A GROUND LEVEL
WAY BUT IF THE THIRTY THOUSAND
FOOT VIEW.
OF THE DIFFERENT ISSUES OF
INVERSE CONDEMNATION WHAT ARE
THE CONSEQUENCES OF TOUCH AND
THAT ONE OF THE CONSEQUENCES OF
LETTING THAT LIABILITY FLOW
THROUGH THE UTILITIES WHAT ARE
THE IMPACTS ON P. G.'S
BANKRUPTCY.
ON TAXPAYERS AND RATEPAYERS IN
THE STATE AND IF SB NINE A ONE
WAS EXPANDED WHAT WOULD BE THE
IMPACT ON RATE PAYERS AND
TAXPAYERS ON PASSING THAT
LIABILITY.
ON TO THEM IN SECURITIZED AHEAD
SO -- IF IF
YOU WANT AN EXAMPLE OF I THINK
SOMETHING A SITUATION WHERE THE
ONLY -- DID
THAT REALLY WELL A COUPLE OF
YEARS AGO REALLY GOOD HAD
INFORMATION THAT WE DID NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO ANYWHERE ELSE.
SO I WOULD REALLY LIKE TO SEE
THE LA --
TAKE A HOLISTIC VIEW OF THAT
TOPIC THIS YEAR BECAUSE AS YOU
KNOW.
OUR GOVERNOR HAS SAID THAT
THAT'S A TOP PRIORITY FOR HIS
ADMINISTRATION IT'S CLEAR THAT
WE NEED TO GET OUR ARMS AROUND
THAT -- IN
ANOTHER.
ON A COMPLETELY DIFFERENT TOPIC.
I KNOW A LOT OF US.
ON THE BUDGET COMMITTEE HAVE
BEEN WATCHING WITH A LITTLE BIT
OF ALARM AT BUT STATE REVENUES
HAVE BEEN DOING IN THE LAST
COUPLE OF MONTHS AND IN DECEMBER
I SAW.
THE THE COLLECTIONS COME IN
UNDER PROJECTIONS AND I KNOW
THAT THERE WAS SPECULATION ABOUT
THAT WAS RELATED TO THE DECLINE
IN THE STOCK MARKET --
WAS -- TO IN
RESPONSE TO CHANGES IN FEDERAL
TAX LAW BUT THEN IN THE MONTHS
THAT HAVE --
PASSED SINCE THEN WE HAVE STE
STILL CONTINUE TO COME IN UNDER
PROJECTION AND SO --
I KNOW THAT THE CRITICAL MONTH
IS GOING TO BE NEXT MONTH THAT
WAS A TROUBLING OR WHETHER OR
NOT THERE WAS A TREND IN A
HARBINGER OF THINGS TO COME --
WHAT OUR CURRENT --
IT ASSESSMENT OF THAT IS THAT
SOME OF IT COULD WELL BE MADE UP
IN APRIL FROM THE FOR AS A
RESULT OF THE TIME IN A FAX.
HOWEVER I DO THINK AS WE MOVE
TOWARD -- A
SECOND FORECAST THAT WE DO EACH
YEAR IN MAY THAT ROUGH TIME TO
COME OUT ROUGHLY WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION --
I WON'T BE SURPRISED IF THE
FORECAST IS ADJUSTED DOWNWARD
SOME SO.
I'M NOT REALLY IN A POSITION.
TO FULLY ANSWER YOUR QUESTION AT
THIS TIME BUT AND YOU KNOW IN IN
ALL THE OPENNESS  THINK.
I THINK WE WON'T BE SURPRISED IF
THERE'S SOME DOWNWARD REVISION
TO THE FORECAST AT THAT TIME.
THANKS I'M SURE WE'LL BE TALKING
MORE ABOUT THIS YEAH.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND THEN
WELCOME SYSTEMATIC WOULD LEAD TO
HAVE YOU ON BOARD THANK YOU
SENATOR.
MONDAY AT THE PHENOMENA ZICH THE
NEXT AND AROUND HERE FOR SOME
TIME [inaudible]
AND MIGHT SAY IT'S A PRODUCT OF
TERM LIMITS.
MAY BE PART OF THE SOCIETAL.
BUT IT'S WHAT I CALL KIND OF
LACK OF VISION.
AND ALSO SIMULTANEOUSLY A LACK
OF INTELLECTUAL CURIOSITY ABOUT
THE HISTORY.
SO WE MAKE A DECISION ABOUT SOME
ISSUE OR SOME LEGISLATION.
IT'S LIKE THE LIGHT BULB JUST
WENT OFF AND HERE WE GO.
BUT WE DON'T THINK WE'LL HOW DID
THAT EVOLVE TO THIS POINT AND
WHAT MAY HAVE BEEN TRIED BEFORE.
THE HISTORICAL CONTEXT IN OTHER
WORDS.
THAT TURNED HIS IMPAIRED US I
BELIEVE ALSO FROM MAKING
DECISIONS ABOUT PROJECTION.
OF THE FUTURE WHAT WILL THIS
MEAN TEN OR TWENTY YEARS.
DOWN THE WHITE.
I REMEMBER ASKING HAVE OF SOME
OF US MEETING IN A GOVERNOR
SCHWARZENEGGER'S OFFICE ON A NEW
WATER PLAN WAY BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND AND NINE WHAT WILL THIS
MEAN FOR OUR GRANDCHILDREN.
AND A BLANK LOOKS AROUND THE
ROOM TOLD ME ALL I NEEDED NO
THAT WASN'T ON ANYBODY'S MIND.
THAT INVESTMENT IN
INFRASTRUCTURE IS IN AFTER THAT
TO THE POINT THEM --
THE THE LA --
DOES A VERY FINE JOB AND I'M NOT
CRITICIZING I'M JUST SUGGESTING
TO KEEP FOCUSED.
ON SOME OF THE HISTORIC
DEVELOPMENTS THAT BROUGHT US TO
THIS MOMENT IN TIME WHEN YOU'RE
ANALYZING WHATEVER IT IS THE
TRAVEL ISING.
IN ADDITION TO TRY TO BE HELPFUL
TO US IN PROJECTING WHAT ARE THE
EVENTUALITIES IN THE FUTURE THAT
WE MIGHT EXPERIENCE.
FROM THIS.
CERTAINLY BECAUSE OF THE
FRAGILITY OF OUR BUDGET
BALANCING AND A LOT OF THINGS
ARE GOING TO HAVE TO BE
ACCOUNTED FOR AS WE MAKE
DECISIONS MOVING AHEAD
[inaudible]
IN ADDITION.
THE SENATE HAS PARTICULAR BEEN
CONCERNED WITH OVERSIGHT FOR A
FEW YEARS.
NOW THAT MEANS THE OVERSIGHT IS
GONE A LITTLE BIT BEYOND JUST
POLICY COMMITTEES IN THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE IN THE BUDGET ITSELF.
OF DOING SOME VERY SPECIAL
LOOKING AT THEWITH THE
OVERSIGHT OF AGENCIES.
IT WOULD WELCOME YOUR HELP IN IN
THAT AS WELL.
WE HAVE SOME TROUBLE AGENCIES
THE DMV BE IN ONE THE OFFICE OF
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY AND IT
HAD MANY DIFFERENT NAMES AS I
THINK THE MOST RECENT IS DO WHAT
DEPARTMENT OF VINTAGE
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY BUT WE'VE
OF SQUANDERED BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS.
THOSE KINDS OF PHENOMENA IN OUR
BUDGET IF YOU COULD HELP US
ANTICIPATE.
LONG TERM CONSEQUENCES
[inaudible]
OF THAT.
AS YOUR LAN THAT VITAL SAY
RESTRUCTURING BUT PRIORITIZING
OR DEPLOYING YOUR RATHER LIMITED
RESOURCES.
THE HISTORICAL CONTEXT
[inaudible]
AND FUTURE.
EVENTUALITIES WOULD BE VERY
HELPFUL TO US.
THANK YOU SENATOR --
YET WE I THINK --
I CAN I TAKE YOUR POINT I THINK
WE DO A LOT OF OUR WORK IS
FOCUSED ON FISCAL AND BUDGET
RELATED MATTERS.
AND WE PROBABLY HAVE LESS --
RESOURCES TO DEDICATE TO DOING --
PROGRAM REVIEWS POLICY AND
ANALYSIS DEPARTMENTAL REVIEWS
AND I THINK --
THAT SOMETHING WE WILL BE
DISCUSSING --
GOING FORWARD AND I MEAN FOR THE
RECORD WE WE ARE NEUTRAL ON THE%
ON THE PROPOSAL FROM --
ASSEMBLYMEMBER OBERNOLTE BUT YOU
KNOW IT IF ANYBODY WERE TO ASK I
THINK YOU KNOW FOR OUR OFFICE
DID HAVE MORE RESOURCES.
AND THOSE WOULD BE IF YOU ASK ME
THOSE WOULD BE SOME OF THE AREAS
THAT I THINK WE WOULD EXPLORE.
IN MORE DETAIL.
AND BE GREAT WELL THE THE
CHARGES DILUTED TO SOMETHING A A
MOMENT AGO THAT.
I CERTAINLY WAS ENTERTAINING AND
AND BECAUSE MAYBE THE
SUBCOMMITTEE OF THIS THAT STAFF
OF SUBCOMMITTEE.
ENQUIRING IF OUR BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEES OF CERTAIN ISSUES
THAT WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL.
AND THEN AS A THE SUBCOMMITTEE
STAFF WILL PREPARE THE MEMBERS.
THAT WOULD BE INSTRUCTED TO US
[inaudible]
THANK YOU. FOR THE MEMBER WEBER.
THE WELCOME IN A AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO OBVIOUSLY HAVING A
VERY --
PRODUCTIVE RELATIONSHIP WITH YOU
IN YOUR OFFICE --
I'M SURE YOU PROBABLY REALIZE
THAT IN THE IN THE BUDGET
PROCESS ALL OF US HAVE CERTAIN
LEVELS OF FRUSTRATION.
IN MUCH OF IT REVOLVES AROUND
THE FACT THAT --
WE HAVE LOTS OF THINGS THAT ARE
NOT --
APPROPRIATELY HANDLE IN
CALIFORNIA WHETHER IT'S DEALING
WITH THE HOMELESS OR DEALING
WITH THE POP ISSUE POVERTY.
OR EDUCATION AND THE DIRECTION
WE'RE GOING IN THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS AND AND PROBABLY IF YOU
PUT IT ALL TOGETHER WE WOULD
PROBABLY ALSO KIND OF THE BE
ALIGNED IN TERMS OF THE THINGS
WE THINK THAT ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT --
YET THE RESOURCES DO NOT ALLOW
US TO ROUTE TO BASICALLY --
OF BASICALLY RESPOND TO OUR
PRIORITIES YOU KNOW OFTEN PEOPLE
SAY THE BUDGET IS A REFLECTION
OF YOUR PRIORITIES.
AND IF THAT WERE THE CASE AND
PROBABLY ARE BUDGET WOULD
REFLECT OUR FRUSTRATION MUCH
MORE THAN ANY ANY KIND OF
PRIORITIES.
BECAUSE WE DO HAVE SOME STE A
NUMBER OF DEEP IN AND SERIOUS
ISSUES AND CHALLENGES.
AND YET --
WE DON'T SEEM TO HAVE A
ADEQUATELY GET TO THE UP TO THE
BOTTOM OF IT AND THEN GIVE US
DIRECTION AS TO HOW WE GET GET
BEYOND THAT YOU KNOW HOW DO WE
DEAL WITH THE ISSUE OF FUNDING.
OUR EDUCATION IN OUR SCHOOLS --
HOW DO WE GET TO THE ISSUE OF
DEALING WITH THE ISSUE OF
POVERTY OR HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS THAT ARE
REALLY BREAKING THE BACK OF
CALIFORNIA?
WITH ALL THE WONDERFUL THINGS WE
DO WE STILL ARE STANDING IN THE
SHADOW OF A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
ISSUES AND CONCERNS.
THAT GET TO THE BASIC ISSUE OF
HIM OUR OF OUR HUMANITY AND OUR
RELATIONSHIP WITH OF THE SOUL.
I'M NOT SURE WHETHER YOUR OFFICE
IS CAPABLE OF DOING IT BUT BUT I
THINK IF YOU TALK ABOUT.
ALL TRYING TO DO THOSE THINGS
THAT ARE DIFFERENT AUG GIVING
SOME DIRECTION TO US THAT WOULD
BE IMPORTANT ALL IT WOULD
PROBABLY PROVIDE MAYBE THE
IMPETUS FOR PEOPLE TO THE TO THE
STEP OUT.
BEYOND THEIR PARTY AFFILIATIONS
OR FEARS OF CITIZENS OR WHATEVER
MAY BE BECAUSE CLEARLY --
WHATEVER WE'RE DOING WE TALK
ABOUT ALL TIME TENS OF OUR TAX
BASE REVENUE --
EVERYBODY SAYS IS NOT RIGHT NO
ONE WANTS TO TAKE IT ON NO ONE
WANTS TO TELL US HOW TO CORRECT
IT.
WELL THE DIRECTION WE NEED TO GO
IN ORDER TO TO RIGHT THE SHIP
ALSO IT'S AN ONGOING CHALLENGE
WE TRIED --
WHEN I WAS HERE THE BUDGET FOR
WHAT --
STARTED THE PROCESS OF ZERO
BASED BUDGETING AND WE DID IT
WITH THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA.
THE GOAL WAS TO DO THAT EVERY
YEAR WITH A DIFFERENT PORTION OF
THE BUDGET AND IT JUST KIND OF
DIED DIDN'T GO VERY FAR --
BUT BECAUSE AS LONG AS YOU
CONTINUE TO FUND THE THINGS
YOU'VE ALWAYS FUNDED.
YOU ALWAYS GET THE RESULTS
YOU'VE ALREADY ALWAYS GOTTEN AND
THAT SEEMS TO BE THE CHALLENGE
IS HOW DO WE GET BEYOND THAT HOW
WE LOOK AT THE EFFICIENCY OR THE
INEFFICIENCY OF MANY AGENCIES.
AND HOW DO WE DEAL WITH THIS IN
A DIFFERENT WAY IF WE DON'T END
UP INCREASING REVENUES WE
OBVIOUSLY HAVE TO LOOK AT WHAT
WE'RE DOING WITH THE REVENUES WE
HAVE.
AND WHAT THE NOT THAT'S THE MOST
EFFECTIVE USE OF IT GIVEN THE
VALUES THAT WE HAVE BUT WE BEGIN
THAT PROCESS IN THERE WERE SOME
CHANGES MADE TO THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA TERMS OF THE
FUNDING OF THE PRESIDENT'S
OFFICE AND SO FORTH AND SO ON
AND THINGS THAT WERE --
KIND OF OUT OF SYNC WITH THE
VALUES OF THE LEGISLATURE BUT WE
HAVE YET TO REALLY --
BEGIN TO CONTINUE TO ASSESS AND
WE SAID WE DO THIS EVERY YEAR SO-THAT --
AGENCIES OR SECTIONS OF THE
BUDGET WOULD KNOW THAT IT WAS
COMING THAT THEY DIDN'T HAVE TO
IT WASN'T LIKE A WOULD BE A ONE
YEAR THING THAT THEY KNEW AND
THREE YEARS WE HAVE.
TO BASICALLY DO ZERO BASED
BUDGETING AND JUSTIFY WHAT THE
MONEY WE HAVE AND AND WHAT
WHAT'S BEING ACCOMPLISHED IN ALL
THIS THERE SO THAT BECOMES
IMPORTANT BECAUSE WE JUST DID
SOMETHING WITH --
I GUESS THE ONE ON WE WERE
GETTING THE RESULTS YOU WANT IN
TERMS OF REHABILITATION --
BUT WE JIM RESPONDED THOSE
THINGS AFTER THE FACT RATHER
THAN BEFORE.
AND IN TERMS OF LOOKING AT WHERE
THE MONEY IS AND HOW IT'S GOING
TO GO AND WHERE IT'S GOING TO GO
TO WHAT IS NOT GOING TO BE
EFFECTIVE WELL WE JUST KIND OF
FUNDING THE SAME OLD THING THAT
WE'VE ALWAYS DONE SO.
I THINK THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL
I'M NOT SURE IF YOU'RE HOPEFULLY
IF YOU GET MORE STAFF TO BE ABLE
TO DO THAT.
BUT I THINK WE DO NEED TO BEGIN
TO REALLY HONE IN ON THAT
BECAUSE THAT'S THE FRUSTRATION.
OF OF AT LEAST MY FRUSTRATION
WHEN EVEN WHEN I WAS CHAIR OF
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES ON THE
BUDGET.
THAT WE HAVE SSI AND YOUKNOW WE
HAVE ALL THESE FOLKS THAT ARE
STRUGGLING WITH LITTLE OR NO
MONEY OUR SENIORS ARE NOT BEING
ADEQUATELY CARED.
FOR AND WHEN WE DO EVERY DAY
EVERY TO EVERYTHING UP IT CAME
OUT TO BE ABOUT WHAT A DOLLAR
FIFTY SAID SOMETHING PER PERSON.
AT WHICH WAS RIDICULOUS.
YOU KNOW FOR THE CLASS WE WOULD
JUST ABSOLUTELY RIDICULOUS AND
SO IT WAS IT WAS AN INSULT EVEN
MOVE FORWARD WITH THE PROPOSAL.
OF BECAUSE OF WHAT LITTLE WE
WOULD BE ABLE TO DO --
SO I THINK THOSE ARE KIND OF
ACCOUNTS OF REALLY HARD
[inaudible]
AND THE WHOLE ISSUE OF HOW DO WE
GET TO ZERO BASED BUDGETING ON A
CYCLE EVERY NOW AND THEN TO
REALLY ASSESS WHAT WE'VE DONE.
THANK YOU YOU --
OKAY.
JUST A JUST JUST TO QUICKLY SORT
OF ANSWER DOCTOR WEBBER'S.
QUESTION ON WE CONTINUE TO DO
ZERO BASED BUDGETING BURKE
CLEARLY WE'RE NOT COMMUNICATING
IT WELL ENOUGH BECAUSE WE'RE
STARTING WITH A FEW.
VERY SMALL DEPARTMENTS AND IT'S
KßT IS THE GOAL IS TO ROLL IT
OUT THROUGHOUT THE A DEPARTMENTS
WITHIN THE STATE AND SO.
THE THING THAT BY MYSELF MISTER
OBERNOLTE MISTER MCCARTY AND
OFFICE TO TALK TO WEBER WAS VERY
INTERESTED IN SO --
CLEARLY WE NEED TO DO A BETTER
JOB OF COMMUNICATING THAT AS
WELL SO THE SYSTEMS ARE YOU
DOING.
I FORGET THE LAST ROUND OF THE
ART SO -- WE
WE WILL.
BRING THAT BACK --
I WILL OBVIOUSLY GET THAT
INFORMATION TO OUR SENATE BUDGET
CHAIRMAN ALSO YOU PROBABLY HAVE
A SEPARATE BUDGET HEARING ON
THAT PARTICULAR ITEMS WHAT WHICH
WHICH WE DID LAST YEAR.
NOT THINKING CLEARLY --
NEEDS A LITTLE MORE.
INFORMATION EXCELLENT.
US SENATOR STONE.
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIRWOMAN PROBLEMS
COLLEAGUES SINCE GREAT TO SEE
YOU SIR AGAIN APPROVED PRECEDED --
TO MEETING YOU IN MY OFFICE AND
GOT A GREAT DEAL OF RESPECT FOR
UNITED LOOKING FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU --
NOW THAT YOU'VE BEEN IN THE
TELL ME HOW YOU FEEL ABOUT THE
INDEPENDENCE OF THE LA OWES
OFFICE VERSUS THE THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE IS THERE IS THAT
GLASS WALL IN BETWEEN BOTH OF
YOU WERE.
MORE OR DO YOU FIND YOURSELVES --
COLLABO COLLABORATING A LOT AND
THEN.
HOW DO YOU RECONCILE SIGNIFICANT --
DIFFERENCES SO AS AN EXAMPLE I
THINK I MIGHT IN LAST YEAR YOUR
BUDGET FORECASTS WAS A COUPLE
BILLION DOLLARS MORE THAN THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WHICH I
WOULD EXPECT IT TO BE THE
REVERSE BUT YOU GUYS WERE A
LITTLE MORE --
LOFTY ON YOUR EXPECTATIONS --
SO I'D LIKE TO KNOW HOW YOU'RE
GONNA RECKONS AND ONE OF MY
GOALS IN THE LEGISLATURE HAS
CERTAINLY BEEN --
TO EMBRACE TECHNOLOGY AND I I'VE
HAD A LOT OF ROAD BIKES AND AND
BRACING TECHNOLOGY BECAUSE ARE
SOME THAT BELIEVE THAT --
THE TECHNOLOGY IS GOING TO
REPLACE.
PEOPLE IN JOBS WHEN IN FACT IT'S
GOING TO CREATE --
HIGHER LEVEL JOBS AND AND MORE
OPPORTUNITIES ESPECIALLY COMING
FROM A STATE THAT HAS SUCH A A
LARGE TECHNOLOGICAL BASE
BASICALLY THE TECHNOLOGY CENTER
OF THE WORLD.
THIS RARE BURKLE'S ACELA
COMMONALITIES SO --
TO KNOW ABOUT --
YOUR YOUR YOUR NEW TENURE AND
pON IT BECAUSE SHOES WITH REGARD
TO TECHNOLOGY AND AND THE
ADVANTAGES OF THE STATE TO
PURSUE CERTAIN TECHNOLOGIES.
TO MAKE US RUN A MORE EFFICIENT
I MEAN CERTAINLY THE DMV IS A
POSTER CHILD FOR HOW WE COULD
PROBABLY USE TECHNOLOGY A LOT
BETTER --
BUT WE NEED SOME INDEPENDENT --
CODIFICATION IF YOU WILL THAT
WE'RE EMBARKING DOWN THE RIGHT
PATH -- OKAY
THANK YOU SENATOR STONE NICE
NICE TO SEE YOU WE I I GUESS THE
FIRST THING I'D SAY IS --
I DON'T KNOW IF WE WOULD
pTO TRY AND RECONCILE OUR
FORECAST WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE BUT POINT OUT HOW WE
ARRIVED AT OUR FOECAST. FOR YOU
TO CONSIDER IN YOUR
DELIBERATIONS.
AND THERE ARE INDEPENDENCE WE
THINK IS AN IMPORTANT
CHARACTERISTIC THAT ALLOWS US TO
BETTER SERVE YOU THE LEGISLATURE.
WE THINK IT LENDS TO THE
CREDIBILITY OF THE CONCLUSIONS
WE REACH AND THEN IF YOU HAVE
CREDIBLE CONCLUSIONS FROM US
THAT YOU CAN THEN USE IN YOUR
DISCUSSIONS.
WE THINK THAT'S A SERVICE THAT
WE PROVIDE TO YOU WE ALSO THINK
OUR CREDIBILITY IS CRUCIAL
ESPECIALLY GIVEN OUR ROLE ON THE
VOTER.
INFORMATION GUIDES IN THE BALLOT
AND VOTER INITIATIVE ANALYSIS.
BECAUSE IF WE WERE TO BE
QUESTIONED IN TERMS OF OUR
INDEPENDENCE AND CREDIBILITY
OVER HERE WHAT'S TO SAY WE
WOULDN'T BE QUESTIONED OVER
THERE SO.
THAT'S ALL TO SAY I THINK IT'S A
VERY.
INTEGRAL PART OF OUR OFFICE IN
IT TO THE IT'S VERY SAD --
IT IT'S A DEEP PART OF THE
CULTURE ACTUALLY I'VE BEEN SET
HAVING INDIVIDUAL MEETINGS WITH
EACH MEMBER OF THE STAFF IN
ADDITION TO MEETING WITH YOU ALL.
AND YOUR STAFF SAID BEEN MEETING
WITH OUR STAFF INDEPENDENTLY
[inaudible]
HI.
AND YOU KNOW IT REALLY COMES
ACROSS IN THESE MEETINGS THAT
THE OFFICE.
IT THE OFFICES INDEPENDENCE IS
AN IMPORTANT CHARACTERISTIC THAT
THAT THEY ALL SEEM TO VALUE
QUITE HIGHLY.
AS FOR TECHNOLOGY.
WE ARE IN THE WORKING ON A
REPORT RIGHT NOW AND IT'S ONE OF
THESE.
TOPICS THAT I THINK WE HAVE A
UNIQUE PERSPECTIVE BECAUSE WE
HAVE A CROSS CUTTING VIEWPOINT.
ON THE STATE TECHNOLOGY IS AN
ISSUE THAT SEASON DIFFERENT
DEPARTMENT AND DEPARTMENTS SORT
OF LIKE INFRASTRUCTURE.
IT'S NOT LIKE THERE'S
NECESSARILY A SINGLE FOCAL POINT
FOR THE ISSUE OF TECHNOLOGY
BECAUSE IT AFFECTS ALL OF US IN
ALL DEPARTMENTS OF THE STATE.
I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
OPPORTUNITY FOR GREATER
EFFICIENCIES IN THE ONE THING I
HAVE BROUGHT UP WITH OUR STAFF
MEMBER THE OTHER DAY IS THAT
THERE'S ALSO RISK.
WE HEAR MORE ABOUT THE RISK OF
CYBERSECURITY IN THOSE KIND OF
THREATS AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR CALIFORNIA YOU
KNOW WE HAVE AN HAD A MAJOR
INCIDENT LIKE THAT AT THIS POINT
BUT THAT'S THE KIND OF THING WE
SHOULD BE TRYING TO THINK AHEAD
ABOUT AND SEE YOU.
HOW WELL PREPARED ARE WE FOR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT AND WHAT
COULD WE DO TO BE MORE PREPARED
SO?
IT'S IT'S ONE OF MY PRIORITIES
AS WELL SENATOR.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER ANY FINAL
QUESTIONS.
SEE NONE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT
[inaudible]
ANYTHING [inaudible]
UP.
WELCOME MISTER PETTIT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION
IN TODAY'S HEARING I THINK OUR
TAKE AWAYS I SAW YOU TAKING
COPIOUS NOTES I APPRECIATE THAT.
I THINK ONE COMMITMENT WE IS THE
JAIL BC WILL CONTINUE TO MAKE TO
YOU IS PERHAPS ADDITIONAL
CONVENING TO CONTINUE TO DRILL
DOWN ON HARSH SHARED KIND OF
INTEREST A RESPONSIBILITY --
IN THE THE RESEARCH TOPICS AND
REPORTS THAT YOU'LL RELEASE --
TWO GB FEE MEMBERS I WANT YOU TO
KNOW THAT --
THE EL AL AND I HAVE HAD TWO
MEETINGS --
SINCE HE'S COME ON BOARD AND WE
HAVE DISCUSSED --
AT LENGTH KIND OF THE EVALUATION
PROCESS I'LL BE HAPPY TO SHARE
IT WITH YOU ALL INDIVIDUALLY IF
YOU'RE INTERESTED BUT WE I AM
COMMITTED TO SHARE THE JAIL BC.
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE --
HELPING TO IDENTIFY GOALS AND
MEASUREMENTS FOR SUCCESS --
AND AT THE ONE YEAR POINT --
I WILL BE DOING --
AN EVALUATION WITH HIM ON JUST
TO MAKE SURE THAT HE'S ON TRACK
IN TERMS OF MEETING THOSE GOALS --
HE'S VERY AMBITIOUS AMBITIOUS
AND EAGER AND SO I'VE WAY DâN
ON SOME IN TERMS OF WHAT I THINK.
IS A REALISTIC OUTCOME AND
EXPECT TWENTY OF US.
AND I STRONGLY SUGGEST THAT HE
PRIORITIZE THAT AND MAKE SURE
THAT YOU'LL BE SEEN MEMBERS --
I THE FIRST ON HIS LIST OF
MEETINGS AND BUDGET COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ECCENTRIC CETERA SO I
SAY THAT TO SAY THAT IF HIS
OFFICE CALLED TO SET UP TIME.
PLEASE HELP HIM BY TRYING TO GET
HIM SCHEDULED ON YOUR CALENDARS --
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE A WITH THAT
ANY CALLS REMARKS YOU'D LIKE TO
MAKE BEFORE WE ADJOURN TODAY'S
HEARING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I WANTED
TO SAY THANKS.
TO YOURS --
STAFF PERSON WHO'S BEEN VERY
HELPFUL AS WELL.
EXCELLENT THANK YOU VERY MUCH IN
TODAY'S MEETING STANDS ADJOURNED
THANK YOU